c'est parfait
et bien écoutez le lieutenant de réserve
ex le tien voyez des cadres il y a très
longtemps et très content de se
retrouver dans cette amphi je suis très
content de me retrouver dans cette amphi
parce que la question du rapport entre
les sujets climats les sujets énergies
et les sujets de défense sont des sons
ça fait l'objet de peu de débats dans
l'espace public ça fait l'objet de peu
de débats dans l'espace public
probablement parce que du côté de
l'armée qui s'appelle pas la grande
muette pour rien c'est normal qu'on est
peu d'expression dans l'espace public de
toute façon et du côté des gens qui
s'intéressent traditionnellement aux
questions d'environnement on va dire que
la chose militaire c'est quand même un
peu caca Berk parce que aller tuer son
voisin c'est quand même pas terrible et
donc il y a assez peu d'intérêt pour ce
que j'ai pu en constater pour la
réflexion sur à quoi ressemble une
stratégie de défense dans le monde de
demain c'est à dire dans un monde qui va
ou qui doit se décarboner et où la
dérive climatique que nous avons mise en
route va continuer et malheureusement
probablement s'amplifier
alors je vais essayer de vous livrer
quelques éléments de réflexion qui
tournent autour de ce sujet donc je vais
j'ai essayé pour une fois de faire une
présentation à peu près adaptée à
l'auditoire et j'espère ne pas mettre
trop trompé
vous savez quand on parle d'armée il y a
un personnage assez incontournable dans
ce pays le grand Charles et le grand
Charles dans un discours qui est quand
même assez connu datant de juin 1940
avec déjà parfaitement compris à peu
près l'essence de ce que je vais vous
raconter ce soir c'est à dire que quand
on parle aujourd'hui de puissance
militaire en fait on parle de
kilowatt-heure il avait parfaitement
compris que ce qui comptait dans la
force brute et un conflit militaire
c'est quand même un rapport de force
brute dans la force brute qui permettait
éventuellement de l'emporter sur
l'ennemi il y avait un sujet absolument
majeur crucial qui était la puissance
mécanique et la puissance mécanique
c'est une question d'énergie
alors de fait au cours des temps dans la
grande transition que nous avons fait
des énergies renouvelables aux énergies
fossiles il y en a une partie qui a
concerné au premier chef les moyens que
nous utilisons pour taper sur nos
semblables ici vous avez une cavalerie
parfaitement renouvelable donc vous
voyez vous avez un cheval parfaitement
renouvelable renouvelé dans une
boucherie chevaline en fin de vie et
dessus un cavalier parfaitement
renouvelable renouvelé en fin de vie
quand il arrivait jusque là
voici un élément de la cavalerie moderne
donc ici vous avez le char français qui
s'appelle le Charles Leclerc et comme
vous pouvez le voir le char Leclerc il
développe la même puissance que si on
avait enlevé son moteur et atteler 1500
chevaux devant alors 1500 chevaux à clé
devant un chat c'est un peu moins simple
à manier que le char tout seul avec son
moteur à l'intérieur et vous comprenez
par ailleurs pourquoi est-ce que dans
les premières époques où il y avait
encore de la confrontation entre les
premiers blindés et les derniers chevaux
évidemment les derniers chevaux
n'avaient pas eu de chance face à ce
genre d'engin
voici de la marine renouvelable
alors la marine renouvelable était faite
en bois renouvelable et à l'intérieur on
mettait des galériens tout à fait
renouvelés en général et l'essentiel du
temps on leur demandait pas trop leur
avis alors ce bateau il est propulsé par
des rames alors j'ai compté vous pouvez
compter aussi il y a 29 âmes on peut
imaginer qu'il y en a 29 de l'autre côté
parce que le bateau ne fait pas que des
ronds et au bout de chakram il y avait
dans les galères les plus puissantes 4 à
5 personnes
vous savez peut-être certains d'entre
vous qui ont déjà écouté mes petits
calculs et les autres je vais vous le
dire un être humain au travail de force
il est capable de développer une
puissance moyenne de l'ordre de 100
watts quand on lui demande un effort sur
quelques heures il y a une vidéo qui
tourne là avec le champion du monde de
cyclisme sur piste qui fait fonctionner
un toaster en actionnant une dynamo en
pédalant comme un comme un fou pendant
une minute alors lui il a des cuisses
qui sont grosses comme en torse et des
bras qui sont grosses comme mes cuisses
et au bout d'une minute de pédalage il
est au bord de la poplexie et avec ça il
a quand même réussi à faire griller du
pain donc il a actionné un grille-pain
qui fait à peu près quoi 700 watts 1800
watts un truc comme ça pendant une
minute mais bon c'est une minute et
c'est le champion du monde du cyclisme
sur piste si vous prenez un organisme
normalement constitué on va dire bon on
est plutôt aux alentours de 100 watts en
puissance moyenne et donc si vous avez 4
à 5 galériens par rame et bien vous
voyez vous avez 4 à 500 watts par rame
fois 60 RAM 5 x 6 30 vous êtes à peu
près à 30 kilowatts de puissance pour
cet engin d'accord c'est pas beaucoup un
30 kilowatts c'est même pas la moitié de
la puissance d'un moteur de voiture
d'aujourd'hui d'accord 500 personnes
quand même alors bon fallait trouver 500
délinquants mais à l'époque c'était pas
très dur
voilà la frégate multimissions de la
marine française et quand on en exporte
de la marine des autres c'est un bateau
dont le moteur est de 30 à une puissance
de 30 mW donc 30 mW c'est l'équivalent
de 1000 galères dans ma galère j'avais
300 galériens donc ce bateau il
développe la même puissance que si
j'avais 300000 galériens d'accord donc
je prends deux ou trois arrondissements
de Paris
la population totale de 2 ou 3
arrondissements de Paris et je les fais
ramer et ça me fait juste la puissance
d'un bateau de la marine fossile alors
évidemment ça c'était parfaitement
renouvelable pas de problème ça c'est
fossile mais bon vous voyez bien que et
enfin voici les débuts de la conquête
des airs alors j'ai pas les moyens de
calculer la puissance de ce truc là il
faudrait que je le fasse probablement
que un jour où j'aurai le temps
j'arriverai à partir du bois brûlé du
etc bon bref de l'air chaud mais enfin
bon manifestement ça faisait pas le
poids dans ce genre de truc qui lui
développe une puissance de quelques
dizaines de mégawatts vous voyez
donc on a pas seulement passé nos modes
de vie des énergies renouvelables aux
énergies fossiles dans les usages civils
ont là aussi fait et c'est ce qui a
permis de gagner les conflits on l'a
aussi fait et c'est ce qui a permis de
gagner les conflits dans les usages
militaires l'armée américaine avant
covid alors je sais pas si maintenant le
rapport est encore exactement le même
parce que la France a un peu baissé mais
avant covid là mais à l'armée américaine
à elle toute seule je dis bien à elle
toute seule consommait le tiers du
pétrole de la France
l'armée américaine et il y a quelques
années il y a longtemps parce que il y a
longtemps que je prends plus d'avion
j'avais été à Washington pour une
intervention qui m'avait été demandé par
la Banque mondiale et j'en avais profité
pour aller discuter au Pentagone avec un
général deux étoiles dont le seul métier
je dis bien le seul métier et de
discuter avec les fournisseurs d'avions
de la Navy pour que les avions
consomment le moins de carburant
possible voilà c'était ça son métier
tellement l'armée américaine était un
consommateur important de carburant
alors certes pour gagner la guerre il
faut avoir des engins puissants qui sont
plus puissants que ceux d'en face mais
il faut également pouvoir les fabriquer
vous avez ici la quantité d'acier qui
est fabriquée par les divers pays du
monde depuis sur les derniers siècles
alors ce que vous voyez de fois depuis
un siècle et bien alors ce que vous
voyez évidemment si vous regardez la
partie droite du graphique c'est
l'explosion industrielle récent de la
Chine oui la production d'acier de la
Chine là tout en haut là qui est
absolument extraordinaire
mais si vous regardez les périodes plus
anciennes et en particulier si vous
regardez l'avant guerre l'avant Seconde
Guerre mondiale là vous voyez après la
canque crise là les États-Unis PAF vous
voyez que le premier producteur d'acier
dans le monde et de très loin c'est les
États-Unis alors qu'est-ce que ça dit
cette affaire là ça dit que en fait
c'était eux qui étaient les mieux partis
pour gagner la Seconde Guerre mondiale
voilà ce que ça dit parce que ça dit
qu'ils avaient de quoi construire des
usines des villes pour héberger les
ouvriers travaillant dans les usines et
évidemment l'acier pour construire des
chars des avions et des bateaux donc le
fait que il y ait eu une fossilisation
globale de l'économie très importante
aux États-Unis
et une explication parfaitement logique
de pourquoi est-ce que ils ont été
capables d'aligner très très rapidement
des moyens militaires en quantité
absolument faramineuse quand ils sont
rentrés dans la deuxième guerre mondiale
le charbon qui sert notamment à
fabriquer l'acier mais pas que c'est
également les États-Unis qui avant
guerre était les plus gros producteurs
mondiaux et vous voyez qu'ils étaient
suivis notamment par la Grande-Bretagne
qui était également à cette époque là
une très grande puissance industrielle
en Europe il faut pas l'oublier et que
ça explique pour partir aussi la
capacité de résistance que les Anglais
ont pu opposer aux Allemands à cette
époque
vous voyez derrière l'Allemagne et vous
voyez le rapport entre l'Allemagne et la
France vous voyez que nous on faisait
pas le poids à cette époque là en terme
de rapport d'utilisation de l'énergie
c'est à dire de la force brute et vous
voyez la Russie ou plus exactement à
cette époque là l'URSS qui était
également un acteur de poids dans la
fabrication d'acier donc avant guerre
vous avez déjà les cartes de la victoire
de 1945 qui sont pour partie sur la
table en ce sens que dans cette
confrontation de force brutes qui est un
conflit et bien vous voyez les
protagonistes du conflit de quel de quel
muscle il dispose au moment où ils vont
jeter les forces dans la bataille et
c'est encore plus flagrant quand vous
regardez ce qui permet d'actionner les
engins de combat en 1940 les États-Unis
produisaient quasiment les deux tiers du
pétrole mondial à eux tout seul
donc aujourd'hui c'est pour ceux d'entre
vous qui suivent l'actualité vous avez
probablement noté que les États-Unis
sont redevenus avec l'essor du shelloil
le premier producteur de pétrole mondial
mais en fait ils n'ont fait que
retrouver une place qui était la leur
avant guerre avant guerre il produisait
encore une fois les deux tiers du
pétrole mondial alors cette affaire là
elle explique également deux choses elle
explique pourquoi est-ce que l'axe sur
le à terme était condamné soit à trouver
du pétrole ailleurs soit à s'effondrer
parce que en fait le seul producteur de
pétrole significatif dans l'axe c'était
la Roumanie les autres n'en avaient pas
les Japonais n'en avaient pas et les les
allemands n'en avaient pas alors ils
avaient du ils avaient des carburants de
synthèse fait à partir de charbon mais
qui était de moins bonne qualité et qui
était il y a notamment un épisode très
intéressant qui a raconté dans le
bouquin qui s'appelle or noir de Mathieu
ozano dans lequel il explique que l'une
des raisons pour lesquelles les Anglais
ont gagné la bataille d'Angleterre c'est
que les Américains leur ont fourni des
carburants d'origine pétrolière pour
leur Spitfire qui permettait au Spitfire
de prendre la domination sur les
messages Schmidt allemand qui n'avaient
que des carburants de synthèse fabriqués
à partir de charbon dont l'indice
d'octane était plus bas
donc là vous avez également en filigrane
les clés j'ai envie de dire de la
victoire de 1945
donc l'axe avait très peu de pétrole et
vous avez également l'explication de
perle Harbor qui est également fourni
dans le même bouquin de Mathieu ozano
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé avec Pearl
Harbor il s'est passé que les Japonais
le seul pétrole qu'ils avaient à leur
disposition c'est celui de ce qu'on
appelait à l'époque les uns
néerlandaises et ce qui s'appelle
aujourd'hui l'Indonésie et ils ont été
occupés l'Indonésie et ils ont été
zigouillés la marine de guerre du
Pacifique américain enfin la marque de
guerre américaine du Pacifique en
espérant qu'ils allaient pouvoir prendre
les Américains de vitesse derrière grâce
à l'approvisionnement en pétrole qu'ils
avaient sécurisé voilà bon ils ont perdu
leur pari mais c'était ça le pari qu'ils
avaient pris ça illustre bien
l'importance stratégique dès cette
époque encore une fois de l'énergie dans
la confrontation alors ça c'est le passé
et maintenant le premier défi qui va se
poser dans le futur aux forces armées
c'est qu'est-ce qu'on va faire avec de
moins en moins de pétrole parce que
c'est bien ça la première question qui
se pose
alors ici vous avez un travail
décidément cette zappette est trop
sensible vous avez un travail le
résultat d'un travail que nous avons
effectué au chiffre project et vous
voyez il y a un petit logo que je me
suis permis de reproduire j'espère que
je vais pas me faire poursuivre pour ça
qui est celui de la DGS c'est la
direction générale des relations
internationales et de la stratégie du
ministère de la Défense et j'ai mis ce
petit logo parce qu'il se trouve que ce
travail nous a été co-financé par la DGS
donc ce que vous savez ce que je vais
vous expliquer maintenant a été
notamment payé pour partie par le
ministère qui emploie un certain nombre
de gens dans la salle alors qu'est-ce
qu'on a fait avec ce travail on est allé
tirer par la manche trois personnes qui
sont respectivement un ancien analyste
pétrole et gaz de l'Agence
internationale de l'énergie l'ancien un
ancien patron de l'exploration de total
donc l'exploration chez un pétrolier
c'est la personne qui cherche où se
trouve de nouveaux gisements et l'ancien
patron de l'évaluation des gisements
chez un pétroliers l'évaluation des
gisements consiste à faire un pari sur
combien de pétrole sortira du gisement
une fois qu'on aura mis en place les
installer des infrastructures de
production donc c'est Monsieur dix
milliards c'est celui qui décide s'il
faut mettre un 5 ou 10 milliards sur la
table indépendamment de ce qu'on pense
du pétrole par ailleurs pour faire
sortir le pétrole ou pas d'un gisement
donc il a intérêt à savoir ce qu'il y a
dedans
et à ces trois là nous leur avons fourni
une base de données de l'ensemble des
gisements pétroliers dans le monde qui
était fourni par reichstad energy il y a
trois sociétés dans le monde qui
fournissent ce genre de données
et on leur a demandé de nous faire un
pronostic sur la quantité de pétrole qui
allait être produite par les 16 premiers
fournisseurs de l'Europe or il se trouve
que l'armée française se trouve sauf
erreur de ma part en France c'est-à-dire
en Europe et donc le carburant dont nous
pouvons disposer sauf à aller faire des
OPA sur des puits à l'étranger quand on
est en opération à l'étranger mais c'est
quand même pas très facile et bien c'est
essentiellement du carburant qui a
commencé par être importé en Europe
donc ce que vous voyez là c'est la
production des 16 premiers fournisseurs
de l'Europe qui se trouvent également
être la production des 16 premiers
producteurs dans le monde or Brésil et
Canada pourquoi en Brésil et Canada
parce qu'il fournissent pas l'Europe
c'est pour ça qu'on a pas trop regardé
enfin on n'a pas publié ce qu'on avait
trouvé pour eux
alors vous avez là dessus la production
passée depuis 1950 comme vous pouvez le
voir sur ce graphique qui monte
extrêmement férocement jusqu'au choc
pétrolier les chocs pétroliers ont été
ont marqué en fait il y a eu un
événement militaire associé au choc
pétrolier mais en fait ça a été le choc
pétrolier aurait lieu quand même en fait
la croissance de la production de
pétrole à l'époque que vous voyez sur ce
graphique elle était juste pas tenable
pendant encore 10 ou 20 ans elle était
juste pas tenable donc en fait les chocs
pétroliers qui sont une rupture de pente
un changement de dérivée sur le
la croissance de la production de
pétrole de toute façon c'était écrit ça
pouvait pas ne pas se produire
est-ce que vous voyez c'est le pronostic
à partir de maintenant
jusqu'en 2050 pour ces 16 pays
vous voyez que d'ici à 2050 la meilleure
estimation que nous ayons à partir des
données et du travail fait c'est que la
production des 16 premiers fournisseurs
de l'Europe devraient être divisé par
deux
ce qui veut dire que leurs exportations
bon vont être diminués enfin votre
divisé par beaucoup plus que deux parce
que bien évidemment une fois que le
pétrole baisse les pays producteurs vont
conserver une fraction croissante du
pétrole résiduel pour leur propre usages
parce que certes comme nous ils ont pris
l'engagement d'être neutre etc mais
enfin ils ont aussi des gilets jaunes et
donc
ils vont ils vont garder une fraction
croissante du pétrole qu'il produisent
pour eux quand vous regardez des pays
qui sont pas ce qu'il y avait qui
étaient exportateur
et qui ont passé leur pic de production
vous vous rendez compte que très peu de
temps après les exportations se mettent
à baisser très très férocement voire ils
peuvent devenir un portateur c'est le
cas de l'Indonésie par exemple qui est
aujourd'hui un portatrice c'est le cas
de l'Egypte qui est devenu qui était
productrice exportatrice et qui est
devenu un portatrice etc le Mexique en
est pas loin donc ça a été le cas des la
Grande-Bretagne par exemple donc vous
avez un donc quand les pays producteurs
vont passer leur pique leurs
exportations vont descendre beaucoup
plus vite que leur production et donc il
y a un vrai sujet
d'approvisionnement en carburant pour
l'Europe alors si c'est une division par
deux on peut imaginer qu'avec les plans
qu'on a pour ceux décarboner pour ceux
etc ça passera si c'est par 20
même avec les plans ambitieux que nous
avons etc ça va quand même poser un
problème
et ça va poser un problème notamment
au moyen militaire sauf à ce que on
commence à arbitrer que c'est des moyens
prioritaires et donc on fera avancer les
frégates et qu'on fera avancer les
avions prioritairement aux voitures des
banlieusards
mais il va y avoir un vrai débat
nécessairement qui va se mettre en place
là dessus
la même direction générale a même des
iris nous a co-financé alors là
également pour la petite histoire ce
travail nous a également été cofinancé
par RTE donc l'entreprise française qui
s'occupe de transporter de l'électricité
et on a confié à peu près à la même
équipe enfin pas tout à fait mais
presque avec la même base de données le
soin de nous faire un pronostic sur la
production future de gaz cette fois-ci
et là il s'agit de la production
mondiale donc vous avez le résultat sous
le sous vos yeux la partie verte c'est
le gaz qu'on appelle conventionnel donc
en gros c'est tout ce qui n'est pas à
gaz de schiste gaz arctique etc et les
couches supérieures là les pollueurs
d'oignons qu'il y a au dessus c'est tout
le reste ce que vous voyez c'est que le
gaz conventionnel sa production
n'augmente plus depuis 2010
quelque chose que j'ai découvert moi
avec ce travail et que si on prend tout
type de gaz en supposant que on se fiche
du clip et bien
nous passerions mondialement le pic aux
alentours de 2030 donc il y a également
un sujet sur le gaz alors le gaz il est
moins crucial directement pour les
opérations des moyens militaires enfin
pour le char une fois qu'il est sur son
terrain de combat mais par contre il est
pas complètement neutre pour fabriquer
le char parce que même le char il est
fabriqué avec de la pétrochimie et le
gaz sert notamment aujourd'hui à
alimenter la pétrochimie
alors c'est pas tout d'être sur le
théâtre d'opération et de se battre en
fait il faut également avoir une base
arrière par exemple les soldats ont
besoin de manger alors en fait là ce que
je vous ai montré c'est qu'on avait
confié aux machines le soin de faire la
guerre très clairement on a confié aux
machines le soin de faire la guerre mais
on a également confié aux machines le
soin de s'occuper de la base arrière
alors par exemple quand les soldats
mangent ils mobilisent également des
machines donc en fait il mobilise
également de l'énergie fossile à tous
les étages
quand on mange aujourd'hui dans tous les
pays occidentaux nous mobilisons à notre
profil des tracteurs alors les tracteurs
il faut des énergies fossiles pour les
fabriquer parce que c'est fait en acier
et il faut des énergies fossiles pour
les faire avancer
nous mobilisons également donc il faut
du pétrole et il faut également du gaz
parce que aujourd'hui quand nous
mangeons en Occident nous mangeons à
partir de culture qui ont été
fertilisées avec des engrais et qui ont
été protégés contre les micro-organismes
et parfois contre les macro-organismes
avec ce qu'on appelle des pesticides
tout ça c'est de la chimie organique
donc ça vient du pétrole et du gaz
les cultures sont également fertilisées
avec de la potasse et des phosphates là
ici vous avez une mine de phosphate par
exemple donc pour exploiter une ligne de
phosphate faut des machines donc nous
avons également ces machines là qui
interviennent quand nous mangeons il
faut des machines pour transporter les
récoltes il faut des machines pour les
transformer parce que c'est peu probable
que sur le théâtre d'opérations comme
vous du reste dans votre vie le soldat
récupère des épis de blé les passes à la
meule fabrique la farine puis fabrique
le pain etc c'est quand même pas
vraiment ça qui fait il touche sa ration
du reste en général les rations qu'on a
sur le sur le quand on est en opération
c'est pas terrible enfin mon époque
c'était vraiment pas terrible
mais c'est des aliments transformés
et donc ça veut dire que il y a
également des machines qui sont
intervenues dans l'affaire pour
transformer les matières premières
agricoles et en faire les aliments qui
vont les rations de combat qui vont être
mangés par le par les soldats bon l'eau
en bouteille ça il en faut dans un
certain nombre d'endroits dans lesquels
c'est compliqué de s'approvisionner
directement dans le fleuve ou
directement au robinet et puis vous avez
également la logistique qui va avec le
froid le chaud la cuisson les camions
etc alors ça ça vaut pour le soldat mais
ça vaut également pour la population
dans son ensemble parce que le fait que
nous soyons aujourd'hui très
raisonnablement débarrassé
collectivement des tâches agricoles et
des tâches de préparation des aliments
puisque en gros vous avez 10% de la
population qui s'occupe de travailler
dans l'agriculture ou dans l'industrie
agroalimentaire laisse au 90% restants
la possibilité ou de faire la guerre ou
de travailler chez Dassault pour
préparer la guerre
donc l'infrastructure des machines a
également considérablement augmenter les
capacités de préparer les conflits et de
mettre du progrès technique dans les
armées et Dieu sait que une large partie
du progrès technique qui bénéficie
aujourd'hui aux gens dans leur vie
civile à trouver heureusement ou
malheureusement la faute à notre code
génétique son origine dans des usages
militaires
tous ceux d'entre vous là qui en ont
marre de m'écouter et qui vont commencer
à tapoter sur leur smartphone et bien
vous allez utiliser un dérivé d'un
réseau de communication qui avait été
mis au point par le Département de la
Défense américain Arpanet qui a débouché
sur Internet
et il y a plein d'autres trucs comme ça
qui quand vous relisez l'histoire en
fait on s'est mis à avoir des usages
civils de technologie qui était au début
essentiellement des technologies
militaires
donc là le fait qu'on ait mis des
machines partout j'ai reviens dans
l'alimentation ça prépare la base
arrière qui va modifier très fortement
la tournure des conflits
alors le soldats vont rarement au combat
tout nu même si c'était permis par la
loi il le ferait pas parce que bon pas
très adapté à aller se battre et là
c'est pareil il faut fabriquer des
vêtements et on a également dans le fait
de fabriquer des vêtements mobiliser des
machines à tous les étages c'est pas
c'est vrai dans la vie civile évidemment
c'est vrai dans la vie militaire c'est
vrai partout donc quand on fabrique des
vêtements par exemple si on utilise du
coton et bien on va mobiliser à notre
profil des machines comme celle-ci qui
mentionnent le coton après l'avoir
planté si on a des fibres synthétiques
et je pense qu'il y a quelques fibres
synthétiques dans le paquetage actuel du
militaire et d'ailleurs on doit trouver
ça quelque part et bien à ce moment on
mobilise un autre profit toute la chaîne
de la chimie organique donc à nouveau
des plateformes pétrolières du gaz de la
transformation avale des raffineries des
vapo crackers etc des machines pour
filer donc là c'est exactement pareil
vous avez des armées de machines là
c'est pour tout le métal le la tenue du
militaire comporte également du métal il
a des voilà avant même avant d'avoir des
exosquelettes
donc ça veut dire que on mobilise
également à notre profit dans cette
histoire des mines métalliques de toutes
sortes on fabrique du verre on fabrique
etc bon bref donc la base arrière là
aussi il est évident que si avant
d'aller au combat le militaire il devait
filer lui-même ses vêtements il doit les
repasser lui-même ses chemises je me
rappelle
sinon il est foutu aux trous il y a un
petit peu de travers mais par contre
s'il devait faire lui-même ses vêtements
vous comprenez bien que ça serait un peu
moins il sera un peu moins productif
voilà donc là j'insiste également sur le
fait que la tournure des conflits n'a
pas été seulement modifiée par la force
brute amenée directement sur le champ de
bataille mais également par la force
brute amenée dans toute l'infrastructure
amont
qui a totalement déformé les sociétés
humaines
il y a également alors cette affaire là
va également poser un problème que je
vais résumer sous forme économique donc
tenez-vous bien les militaires devraient
être des ennemis de la sobriété parce
que la sobriété dans la société dans son
ensemble va nécessairement poser la
question de l'affaiblissement de la base
arrière
qui fournit une partie du muscle à la
défense nécessairement c'est une des
contradictions qu'on va devoir gérer
un petit calcul que certains d'entre
vous connaissent probablement si on
regarde la puissance globale de
l'ensemble du parc de machines qui est
disponible sur terre donc ça c'est pour
préparer ma conclusion économique que je
vous fais ça
la puissance globale de l'ensemble du
parc de machines disponible sur terre
en gros un petit calcul d'ordre de
grandeur permet d'arriver à la
conclusion que ce parc de machines a
démultiplié la puissance musculaire des
individus des hommes par des hommes et
des femmes par 200 de l'humanité par 200
alors c'est notamment ça que vous
retrouvez dans les multiples
extraordinaires que je vous ai montré
tout à l'heure extraordinaire au sens de
hors de l'ordinaire
que je vous ai montré tout à l'heure
entre les moyens de combat renouvelables
et les moyens de combat qui ne le sont
pas les moyens de combat fossiles
alors ce multiple il est un peu moins
important à l'échelle de l'humanité dans
son ensemble d'abord parce que tous les
pays du monde n'ont pas des frégates
multimissions et des chars Leclerc il y
a un certain nombre de pays qui ont pas
ça mais
[Musique]
il est quand même très conséquent en
gros de l'ordre d'un facteur de sang
alors cette affaire là a une conséquence
c'est que la quantité de transformation
que nous sommes aujourd'hui capable
d'opérer dans le monde grâce aux
machines
elle est en gros 200 fois plus
importante que si on n'avait que les
muscles de l'humanité pour transformer
la matière autour de nous
ce qui veut dire que la base arrière qui
profite notamment aux militaires quand
ils ont besoin d'aller se battre
s'il y avait pas l'énergie abondante
s'il y avait pas l'énergie fossile elle
serait 200 fois plus faible c'est une
autre manière de dire la même chose
alors traduit en terme économique ça
veut dire que le PIB mondial dont vous
voyez que il suit depuis quelques
décennies au moins l'énergie utilisée
c'est-à-dire en fait le parc de machines
en service et bien il est directement
fonction l'économie mondiale est
directement fonction de la quantité de
machines qu'on peut faire fonctionner et
ça rejaillit nécessairement sur un
certain nombre d'usages dont la défense
alors il se trouve qu'en France quand on
regarde comment évolue la variation de
l'approvisionnement énergétique de notre
pays
sur les 50 dernières années on est
capable de lire en fait ce qui nous
arrive sur le plan économique vous voyez
il y a 60 ans maintenant presque
l'énergie en France augmentait chaque
année on va dire à peu près de 5% par an
et c'est l'époque où le PIB français
augmentait de 5 à 6% par an aussi
c'est l'époque des trentes glorieuses
c'est l'époque où tout le monde s'équipe
en maison en machine à laver en voiture
etc
et où Johnny se met à chanter
et puis vous voyez qu'avec le temps
vous avez ce taux de croissance qui
baisse que les chocs pétroliers que vous
voyez
là et là en fait c'est juste des
accidents de parcours sur une tendance
lourde
qui elle est beaucoup plus marquée avec
une baisse régulière du taux de
croissance de l'approvisionnement
énergétique en 2008 on passe par
l'origine 0 et depuis le taux de
croissance est devenu un taux de
décroissance c'est à dire que chaque
année nous avons entendance de moins en
moins d'énergie qui rentre dans le pays
et l'inversion date de 2008 alors
qu'est-ce qui se passe en 2008 est-ce
que nous avons tout d'un coup élu un
exécutif qui prend le problème
climatique à bras le corps qui met la
tonne de carbone à 300 euros et qui
baisse la vitesse sur autoroute à 60
km/h non c'est pas du tout ça qui s'est
passé il s'est passé qu'on est passé par
le pic de production du pétrole
conventionnel dans le monde
qui a notamment provoqué la crise dite
des subprimes et que ça a mis un énorme
coup de frein à l'activité économique
dans la totalité des pays de l'OCDE en
fait si je vous montrais ça dans la zone
OCDE dans son ensemble vous auriez
exactement la même évolution et si je
vous montrais ça dans tous les autres
pays etc voilà il y a quelques pays qui
s'échappent un peu avec des exportations
mais globalement ça c'est ça c'est ça
c'est fait un peu dans tous les pays de
cedea à peu près pareil
et ça vous explique pourquoi
la croissance
de l'économie française a également
décélérer de plus en plus depuis cette
époque là alors pourquoi je vous parle
de ça parce que dans un pays qui est de
moins en moins en croissance et qui à
mon sens va passer au sens de l'économie
vrai dans pas très longtemps dans une
forme de récession structurelle nous
avons un tout petit sujet qui s'appelle
le budget
nous avons un tout petit sujet qui
s'appelle le budget puisque l'essentiel
des recettes de l'État sont des
fractions du PIB la TVA c'est une
fraction du PIB c'est une fraction des
dépenses des ménages c'est une fraction
du PIB les charges sociales c'est une
fraction du PIB l'impôt sur le revenu
c'est une fraction du PIB l'IMP l'impôt
sur le bénéfice des sociétés c'est une
fraction du PIB les seuls impôts qui ne
sont pas des impôts qui sont une
fraction du PIB c'est des impôts qui
sont basés sur des actifs
la taxe foncière ça c'est pas un impôt
qui est une fraction du PIB encore que
la valorisation de l'immobilier
elle-même
est en lien avec le PIB la taxe qu'on
avait sur les téléviseurs
ça c'est une taxe qui est indépendante
du PIB d'accord mais les taxes les
recettes de l'État qui sont
indépendantes du PIB ou raisonnablement
indépendant du PIB sont nécessairement
des impôts de stock d'accord des impôts
qui sont assis sur des actifs c'est ce
en général qu'on n'aime pas quand on a
beaucoup d'actifs et quand on a beaucoup
d'actifs on est souvent proche du
pouvoir donc en général c'est plutôt les
impôts voilà on met un coût ISSF et puis
on l'enlève et puis on le remet enfin
bon bref mais c'est pas une fraction
significative des recettes fiscales du
pays la fraction significative des
recettes fiscales du pays c'est des
fractions c'est prélevé sur les flux
c'est à dire c'est prélevé sur le PIB
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire pour la
grande muette cette histoire ça veut
dire que dans un contexte dans lequel le
PIB n'est plus en croissance
les recettes fiscales ne sont plus en
croissance et les moyens de l'État ne
sont plus en croissance
et donc les arbitrages budgétaires vont
devenir beaucoup plus violents
beaucoup plus violents
ce que vous vivez depuis quelques années
parce que des arbitrages budgétaires ça
date pas d'aujourd'hui d'accord en fait
sa préfigure quelque chose qui en toute
bonne logique devrait s'amplifier alors
il n'y a pas que pour l'armée que ça
devrait s'amplifier ce que je suis en
train de vous dire va également
s'amplifier pour l'hôpital ça va
également s'amplifier pour
l'enseignement ça va être etc on va on
va commencer à avoir des vrais sujets de
d'arbitrage de la dépense publique alors
on peut compenser ça en disant bah on
s'endette encore et encore et on crée
une dette perpétuelle c'est une
possibilité on fait une pyramide de pont
d'hyperpelle voilà
mais au bout du bout si on se rappelle
que ce que nous allons au fond ce sont
des moyens physiques ça revient quand
même à se poser la question de savoir si
notre acier on le met dans construire un
logement de plus ou donc construire un
char voilà ça c'est quand même une
question qu'on va nécessairement être
obligé de se poser
celle-là on va alors aujourd'hui on la
traduit de manière macroscopique à
travers des arbitrages budgétaires mais
si je la retraduis de manière physique
c'est exactement ça la question que ça
va qu'on va devoir se poser et les
compétences que nous avons quand on a
des ingénieurs qui savent faire des
structures c'est pareil la question se
posera de savoir si on doit les coller
dans la rénovation du bâtiment ou la
construction des trains ou dans la
fabrication de nouveaux porte-avions
voilà on va devoir se poser ce genre de
question probablement
encore une fois je l'illustre à travers
la contrainte budgétaire mais elle ne
fait que de traduire de manière
transversale avec une unité imparfaite
c'est à dire les euros une vraie
contrainte
on va avoir un dernier petit sujet
aujourd'hui ne vous aura pas échappé
qu'il n'y a plus une seule mine de fer
en activité en France d'où vient le
faire des Charles Leclerc
pas de France d'accord puisque
nous importons tous les matériaux dont
nous avons besoin alors il y a pas que
pour faire des chars Leclerc on apporte
les matériaux on apporte également le
minerai de fer pour faire les voitures
et les constructions alors ça n'a pas
posé de problème pourquoi ça n'a pas
posé de problème parce que comme vous
pouvez le voir sur ce graphique depuis
dans la salle beaucoup plus logique que
les Français jamais compris pourquoi les
Français disaient 70 mais bon
on dit bien 50 et pas 40 10
et bien depuis 1970
vous voyez que la part des échanges dans
le PIB mondial a considérablement
augmenté on était à peu près à 25% et on
est monté à peu près à 60%
c'est la mondialisation la
mondialisation ça veut dire que en gros
ce que vous consommez peut être
raisonnablement disjoint de l'endroit où
ces produits c'est ça la mondialisation
et du reste c'est le monde dans lequel
on vit aujourd'hui essayer d'aller chez
un distributeur mais trop chez vous
Ikea chez nous et d'acheter une
casserole vous verrez que la probabilité
qu'elle soit made in chez nous et quand
même pas très élevé et c'est pareil pour
les vêtements ensuite c'est même pareil
pour les voitures c'est enfin voilà donc
c'est pareil en gros pour tous les
objets de consommation ça s'appelle la
mondialisation alors la mondialisation
elle est passée à date par un maximum au
moment du maximum du de la production de
pétrole conventionnel et depuis elle
commence à décliner
vous comprenez bien que dans un monde
qui n'aura plus de pétrole du tout alors
je ne sais pas à quelle date nous sommes
je sais pas si c'est dans un siècle dans
deux siècles dans 50 ans ou dans bref
mais dans un monde qui n'a plus de
pétrole du tout la mondialisation
deviendra croupion parce que quand vous
avez un porte-conteneur ou un minéralié
de 300000 tonnes vous avez pas le faire
avancer à la voile vous savez pas non
plus faire avancer avec des galériens
même si vous avez beaucoup de galériens
vous n'avez et du reste les militaire le
savent bien que un seul moyen de
puissance des carbonées ça s'appelle le
nucléaire donc vous n'avez qu'un seul
moyen de puissance des carboner c'est le
nucléaire donc pour faire avancer un
gros bâtiment or combustible fossile il
y a qu'un seul truc qui fonctionne c'est
un réacteur voilà la voile ça marche pas
ce qui veut dire que dans un monde qui
n'a plus de pétrole comme aujourd'hui
vous avez 40000 bateaux de fortonnage
dans le monde et que je doute que en
nucléarise 40000 bateaux de fortonnage
dans les 30 ans qui viennent dans un
monde qui est en décrue pétrolière
rapide vous allez avoir une décrue de la
mondialisation
et une décrue de la mondialisation ça
veut dire que ça sera physiquement plus
difficile de faire venir en France
l'acier que nous n'avons plus enfin le
faire que nous n'avons plus le cuivre
que nous n'avons pas les temps que nous
n'avons pas le plomb que nous n'avons
pas lors que nous n'avons pas ils
doivent rester un peu celle-ci mais
enfin pas beaucoup
etc il y a pas que l'uranium dans cette
affaire parce que je sais que l'uranium
est un truc qui obsède les gens non non
on s'en fout enfin on s'en fout c'est un
problème parmi 92 et 92 éléments dans le
tableau de m'en aller F bon on va avoir
un vrai sujet avec plein d'autres métaux
dans un monde qui se démondialise
et là c'est pareil on devra choisir si
le cuivre résiduel on le colle dans une
éolienne ou on le colle dans un char
Leclerc
voilà ça va faire partie des choses
bien évidemment beaucoup de gens qui
s'intéressent à l'environnement moi le
premier ne souhaite pas qu'il y ait des
conflits
et je le redis dans le discours public
comme une bonne partie de la mouvance
environnementale en gros aime pas trop
parler des occasions de se tuer les uns
les autres à raison
c'est les questions que je suis en train
de poser là qui sont des questions
réelles quand même les individus
lorsqu'ils sont sont des questions qui
aujourd'hui sont très très pour prendre
un terme militaire sous l'écran radar
les théâtres d'opérations ont changé à
cause de l'énergie on en parlait avec le
général juste avant de démarrer cette
conférence la guerre de 1914 était une
guerre essentiellement rurale on a mis
les pas les tranchées dans les villes on
a mis les tranchées en dehors des villes
la guerre de 1945 en 39-45 était déjà
une guerre beaucoup plus urbaine
alors pourquoi est-ce que le théâtre
d'opérations ont changé tout simplement
parce que les gens n'habitent plus au
même endroit parce que les richesses
entre guillemets les centres de pouvoir
les trucs névragiques sont plus au même
endroit en 1900 ou en 1850 le truc
névralogique c'était l'agriculture et
c'était les endroits où les lieux de
pouvoir là où il y avait le roi ou son
équivalent etc après c'était plutôt les
usines les les alliés les forces
aériennes alliées ils ont plutôt
bombardé les usines que bombarder les
champs quand voilà c'était plutôt ça
qu'on allait chercher donc les théâtres
d'opération ont changé alors les villes
elles ont beaucoup grossi à cause de
l'énergie
voici le test
Lutèce bon Lutèce c'est l'île de la Cité
plus 3 bricoles autour
je sais pas comment il y a d'Américains
parce qu'il y a que aujourd'hui qui
habitent dans l'île de la Cité mais
enfin on va dire quelques milliers donc
Lutèce il y a peut-être trois Suisses
rigolaient pas qui sont planqués dans
l'île de la Cité aussi
donc l'Utah il se faisait à peu près 10
000 personnes pourquoi est-ce que Lutèce
faisait que 10 000 personnes et pas
beaucoup plus parce que la première
fonction des civils comme des militaires
ou plutôt directement la première
nécessité c'est de manger
à l'époque de Lutèce l'énergie est rare
renouvelable mais rare
ou plus exactement rare par rapport à
aujourd'hui précisément parce que
renouvelable malheureusement et donc
pour faire manger une ville vous n'avez
à votre disposition que ce qui est
dégagé comme surplus agricole à une
distance de la ville qui est quelques
jours de transport parce que au-delà de
quelques jours de transport ça commence
à devenir compliqué de faire venir des
animaux vivants ça commence à devenir
compliqué de faire venir des récoltes
sans qu'elles prennent la pluie etc bon
bref quelque chose de transport un peu
plus loin mais bon en gros
surtout pour les pondéreux les céréales
le surplus agricole à l'époque est très
faible un agriculteur enfin un paysan il
arrive à se nourrir lui et il arrive à
nourrir une fraction de personnes qui
fait autre chose c'est ça le c'est ça
ratio et en quelques jours de transport
à pied ou en charrette à beuh vous allez
pas très loin donc le surplus agricole
dégagé par un disque dont le rayon est
trois jours de marche à pied pour dire
les choses simplement ça permet de faire
vivre 10000 personnes bon alors les
riches dans Lutèce arrive quand même à
faire venir des olives un peu loin un
peu d'huile d'olive je sais pas quoi un
peu de vin mais globalement c'est ça
l'idée
avec l'énergie très abondante on a été
capable de faire considérablement
grossir les villes pour plusieurs
raisons d'abord on a vidé les campagnes
en remplaçant les gens par des tracteurs
et des usines d'engrais
ensuite on a mis les gens dans les
périphéries des villes qui sont trouvés
plus tard du reste un peu dans la ville
dans des usines mais enfin ça a fait
grossir la connurbation puis on a fini
par mettre les gens dans des bureaux qui
sont également situés en ville tout ça
en fait est le reflet de la croissance
de l'approvisionnement énergétique les
gens sont dans les bureaux parce que les
machines bossent à notre place donc nous
on a le temps d'être dans un amphi à
écouter un troubadour en train de
pérorer
Jacquouille la fripouille passerait une
passerelle la tête là par la porte et il
dirait que vous êtes en train d'écouter
un troubadour si vous lisez si vous lui
expliquez vous êtes en train de
travailler il se marre d'accord parce
qu'à son époque travailler c'est pas du
tout être assis dans un fauteuil à
écouter quelqu'un ça c'est le noble qui
fait ça pas les pas le brave paysan
donc les machines travaillant à notre
place on a pu se mettre dans les bureaux
à contrôler
les machines qui sont maintenant dans
les champs bon il y a quelques
agriculteurs et dans les usines bon il y
a quelques ouvriers mais globalement
voilà les machines qui bossent partout
ailleurs et comme c'est quand même plus
pratique quand on veut contrôler les
systèmes d'être tous les uns à côté des
autres pour communiquer et bien on sait
rassemblé tous autant que nous sommes
dans les villes aujourd'hui 80% de la
population française est urbaine alors
ce mouvement il a été général sur terre
vous voyez ici la fraction en Chine de
la population qui habite en ville en
fonction de l'approvisionnement
énergétique par personne et bien vous
avez exactement la même évolution que
celle que nous avons eu en France
c'est-à-dire plus il y a d'énergie par
personne plus il y a de machines au
travail plus il y a de machines au
travail plus les gens se mettent dans
les vides
ce qui veut dire qu'une civilisation
très urbaine est une civilisation très
dépendante de l'énergie abondante
c'est bien comme ça qu'il faut le
comprendre
voilà je vous ai pris un pays pas très
loin de la France le Maroc ou de temps
en temps il y a quelques petites
échauffourées au sud du reste et vous
voyez qu'on a également la même
évolution et on a la même évolution dans
le monde donc en fait voici une image
qui est issue du monde sans fin et qui
représente la façon dont les pays
occidentaux ont construit le monde avec
l'abondance énergétique nous avons
construit une Métropolis avec quelques
personnes quelques paysans je ne
rétracteur quelques ouvriers dans leurs
usines essentiellement des machines au
travail et nous avons mis une armée de
colle blanc certains d'entre eux portant
des galons
dans des bureaux à l'étage au dessus
pour contrôler l'ensemble du système
alors bien évidemment si je reviens à la
question militaire ça veut dire que
notamment pour déstabiliser un pays
c'est pas nécessaire d'aller tuer les
gens qui sont là il suffit d'aller
s'occuper de mettre un peu le bazar dans
le système qui est en dessous
ça suffit
aujourd'hui si par exemple en France on
supprime les camions on ferait mourir de
faim les villes
parce que il y aurait plus les moyens
logistiques d'acheter de la nourriture
c'est pas avec les trois fermes
verticales qui font pousser deux fraises
dans Paris que vous allez nourrir les
Parisiens c'est même pas en mangeant les
pigeons ce qui serait pourtant une bonne
idée il y en a trop
mais il y a aussi trop de Parisiens donc
vous comprenez bien que sans camion
demain matin
j'insiste les grandes villes meurent de
faim
si nous sommes dans un conflit dans
lequel l'ennemi a notamment pour
vocation de nous couper les routes de
l'approvisionnement énergétique
le système que nous avons bâti
aujourd'hui est considérablement plus
vulnérable que le système plus rural que
nous avions il y a un siècle
considérablement plus vulnérable
alors dans cette affaire là je vous ai
parlé de la partie amont c'est-à-dire la
dépendance de notre civilisation à
l'énergie et notamment la dépendance de
l'appareil militaire à l'énergie pour
donner corps à la maxime du grand charme
maintenant on va s'occuper de l'autre
versant de la faire qui est également un
sujet pour les forces armées c'est à
dire le changement climatique alors le
changement climatique trouve son origine
dans le fait que l'espèce humaine est en
train de modifier à grande vitesse la
composition chimique de l'atmosphère
dans l'atmosphère vous avez comme vous
le savez probablement 80% d'azote qu'il
nous fait rien ni du bien ni du mal 20%
d'oxygène on apprécie plutôt d'avoir à
respirer plus quelques gaz mineures dans
les gaz mineurs qui sont présents dans
l'atmosphère depuis très longtemps vous
avez notamment du méthane de la vapeur
d'eau et du dioxyde de carbone et ces
gaz là plus d'autres s'appelle des gaz à
effet de serre alors pourquoi est-ce
qu'on les appelle des gaz à effet de
serre pour une raison très simple c'est
qu'il crée un effet de serre
c'est-à-dire que ils augmentent la
quantité d'énergie qui reste confiné
près du sol la raison pour laquelle il
crée cet effet c'est que ces des gaz
pour ceux d'entre vous qui ont fait des
vieilles études de physique dans la dans
l'assistance c'est des gaz qui possèdent
des réabsorption dans l'infrarouge
terrestre voilà c'est ça un gaz à effet
de serre par définition un gaz à effet
de serre c'est un gaz qui possède des
réabsorption c'est-à-dire qu'il est
opaque oreille à certaines longueurs
d'onde émise par la surface terrestre
à partir du moment où vous en rajoutez
dans l'atmosphère vous augmentez
l'opacité de l'atmosphère aux
infrarouges terrestres et après et à
partir de là vous confinez l'énergie
plus près du sol
donc l'effet de serre c'est un c'est un
c'est un système de modification du
profil vertical de température dans
l'atmosphère l'atmosphère près du sol se
réchauffe et corrélativement ça c'est un
truc qui va intéresser les aviateurs la
température de la stratosphère diminue
parce que si vous arrivez absolument si
vous interprétez si vous interceptez
pardon plus de rayonnement près de la
surface il y en a moins qui va être
intercepté provenant du bas par la haute
atmosphère et donc on va refroidir la
haute atmosphère une démarche absolument
individu indubitable pardon du fait que
c'est bien l'espèce humaine qui a
modifié de climat depuis des années 70
c'est que les ballons sondes qui
permettent de mesurer la température de
la stratosphère depuis ces années là
montre un refroidissement continu de la
stratosphère depuis des années 60
je suis désolé je ne referai plus
et ça c'est encore une fois totalement
incohérent avec un surplus de
rayonnement solaire parce qu'un surplus
de rayonnement solaire enverrait plus
d'ultraviolet sur la terre et donc
réchaufferait la stratosphère au travers
de l'interception de ces ultraviolets
par zone
alors que plus d'effet de serre
refroidit la stratosphère parce que il y
a plus de rayonnement qui est intercepté
d'orienter ce qui est intercepté dans
les basses couches de l'atmosphère donc
il y a juste zéro débat sur le fait que
ce qu'on est en train d'observer en ce
moment ça peut pas être le soleil ça
peut pas être des variations naturelles
du climat c'est dû à l'espèce humaine
zéro débat sur l'effet scientifique mais
alors donc du coup ça veut dire que la
différence de température et j'y
reviendrai après pour les les
modifications que ça va engendrer la
différence de température entre le sol
et la stratosphère va augmenter
donc ça va augmenter la puissance de la
conviction atmosphérique donc les
planeurs militaires vont être un peu
plus secoués voilà
mais pour le moment nous en sommes pas
encore là
donc on met des gaz à effet de serre
dans l'atmosphère je vais venir avant un
autre une moins bonne fin nouvelle un
peu moins sympathique
dans les gaz à effet c'est-à-dire que
nous rajoutons pardon dans l'atmosphère
il y a notamment le dioxyde de carbone
qui est donc le principal d'entre eux
alors le dictionnaire est en bien fait
le dioxyde de carbone est un oxyde
c'est-à-dire que c'est une espèce qui
est chimiquement très stable et en
particulier il n'a pas de processus
spontané d'épuration tant qu'il est dans
l'air pour que le dioxyde de carbone
soit retiré de l'atmosphère il faut
qu'il se trouve au contact du sol ou là
il va être retiré soit par l'action de
la végétation avec l'aide de l'énergie
solaire c'est pour ça qu'on parle de
photosynthèse il y a photon dans
photosynthèse il faut l'énergie du
soleil pour casser la molécule de CO2 en
deux sinon elle se casse pas elle est
trop stable et l'autre processus qui
peut retirer du CO2 de l'atmosphère
c'est par dissolution dans l'eau
océanique et là aussi pour ceux d'entre
vous à qui ça rappellent les vieux
souvenirs c'est un équilibrage de
pression partielle entre l'atmosphère et
l'océan donc il y a plus de place dans
l'océan pour y mettre du CO2 en
provenance de l'atmosphère craque ça
passe dans ce sens là mais c'est
réversible
c'est réversible en particulier si on
chauffe l'océan la solubilité en CO2
diminue et à ce moment il peut recracher
une partie du CO2 qu'il contient
à cause de cette très grande stabilité
du CO2 dans l'air tant qu'il est dans
l'air et de la lenteur des processus de
soustraction de l'atmosphère
la dérive climatique que nous avons
engendré et pour partir réversible alors
pour être plus précis
nous avons créé un surplus de CO2 dans
l'atmosphère un jour on finira bien par
arrêter les émissions et bien un siècle
après arrêt des émissions la moitié une
petite moitié du surplus de CO2 qui a
été créé sera toujours dans l'air
un millier d'années après arrêt des
émissions un quart du surplus que nous
avons créé sera toujours dans l'air et
10.000 ans après arrêt des émissions
entre 10 et 15% du surplus de CO2 que
nous avons créé sera toujours dans l'air
ce qui veut dire que l'état de
l'atmosphère préindustriel nous ne le
retrouverons jamais du restant des temps
historiques jamais
et comme une partie des conséquences
dont je vais parler maintenant sont
liées à ce surplus de CO2 ça veut dire
que pour certaines conséquences la
dérive climatique que nous avons mise en
route est désormais inarrêtable
ce qui est encore en notre pouvoir c'est
dans modérer l'ampleur et il est urgent
de le faire mais il faut comprendre que
l'état de très grande stabilité du
climat
qui avait été qui avait marqué le
système terre sur les 10 000 dernières
années avant qu'on commence à faire
joujou avec le charbon et le pétrole et
bien cette stabilité du climat et qui a
notamment permis la sédentarisation de
notre espèce donc les conflits armés et
bien c'est quelque chose qu'on ne
retrouvera plus malheureusement donc à
partir de maintenant nous allons devoir
vivre dans un climat instable voilà
évidemment c'est pas très sympathique et
là vous me voyez venir avec le thème de
ce soir quelque chose d'instable en
général c'est pas terrible pour la peine
malheureusement
ce problème là va s'échelonner sur des
durées de temps qui évidemment dépasse
l'entendement parce qu'il dépasse une
vie humaine alors vous êtes mort bien
avant dans 60 ans pour une bonne partie
des gens qui sont dans la salle
notamment ceux qui comme moi ont moins
de cheveux plus de cheveux du tout ou
des cheveux gris il faut que j'avais
fait cette planche pour mes étudiants au
début et puis j'ai eu la flemme de la
modifier quand je m'adressais à des gens
plus âgés
mais dans voilà donc ça va ça va si je
le dis et
le problème c'est que ça va très au-delà
d'un mandat électoral d'une stratégie de
long terme dans une entreprise qui est
dans une entreprise côté qui est 3 ans
les bonnes années et six mois les
mauvaises ça dépend du cours de l'action
et ça va même très au-delà d'une loi de
programmation militaire
donc on est en train de parler d'un
processus qui s'échelonne sur des pas de
temps qui sont totalement
disproportionnées par rapport au pas de
temps que nous utilisons classiquement
pour gérer nos petites affaires civiles
ou militaires
c'est l'un des problèmes majeurs de
cette affaire
alors si on parle un peu de la
déstabilisation que nous risquons
voici une carte qui représente les
écosystèmes installés en Europe sur les
siècles écoulés alors j'ai mis actuel
mais en fait c'est plutôt sur les
siècles écoulés parce qu'ils ont
malheureusement commencé à souffrir les
écosystèmes à partir du moment où on les
supprime pas pour faire des choses
essentielles comme le camp de congère
c'est des choses accessoires comme des
champs des routes et des écoles donc si
on ne supprime pas les écosystèmes pour
y laisser place à des infrastructures ou
des occupations humaines et bien nous
avons en Europe essentiellement des
forêts c'est-à-dire où nous avions plus
exactement essentiellement des forêts
c'est-à-dire des grosses espèces
végétales parce que il pleut
suffisamment et il fait ni trop froid ni
trop chaud
voici l'Europe il y a 20 000 ans alors
il y a 20 000 ans le climat planétaire
est très différent nous sommes au coeur
de la dernière ère glaciaire et le il
fait beaucoup plus froid la géographie
européenne en conséquence ne ressemble
pas du tout à ce à quoi elle ressemble
aujourd'hui d'abord je ne sais pas si
aujourd'hui vous avez le plaisir de
temps en temps de faire des manœuvres
arrosées de vodka avec vos amis suédois
mais à l'époque c'est sûr que non parce
qu'il y a pas de suédois ils sont sous
la glace et il y a pas plus de
Norvégiens il y a pas plus de finlandais
tous ces braves gens sont sous la glace
le nord de la Sibérie est sous la glace
également et les cadaniens tabernacles
sont également sous la glace et enfin
s'il y a des gens qui viennent du
Sud-Ouest ici j'ai une bonne nouvelle
pour vous les Irlandais sont sous la
glace les Écossais aussi mais les
Écossais on arrive à les battre au rugby
ça c'est déjà plus facile
voilà il y a d'énormes de glace donc qui
recouvre le nord de l'Europe l'eau qui
constitue ces calottes de glace
et provient d'un énorme transfert qui a
eu en provenance de l'océan donc c'était
vaporé c'est tombé sous forme de neige
et puis il y a eu un énorme transfert
comme ça et comme la tectonique des
plaques n'a pas fondamentalement modifié
le fond de l'océan depuis cette époque
le niveau de l'océan est plus bas de 120
mètres
voilà donc
là il y a pas de brexit
continuité territoriale donc tous les
conflits qu'il y a eu entre la France et
la Grande-Bretagne ça aurait été des
conflits régionaux et pas des conflits
entre nations ou peut-être pas en tout
cas et puis il n'y a pas de club de
régates pour aller regarder sur la
Manche il y a pas de manche
les écosystèmes étant pardon le climat
étant beaucoup plus froid il est
beaucoup plus sec parce que dans un
climat plus froid vous avez moins
d'évaporation donc moins de
précipitations et en gros dans une
Europe qui ressemble à ce qu'il y a
actuellement
au nord de la Sibérie là totalité de la
population française c'est les effectifs
actuels de l'armée c'est à dire à peu
près 100 000 personnes
voilà ce qu'est la totalité de la
population française à l'époque dans un
climat glaciaire
quand l'Europe est passée de l'état de
gauche à l'état de droite ça c'est
évidemment opéré dans le cadre d'un
climat qui s'est réchauffé et bien le
réchauffement planétaire qui a conduit à
cette modification des paysages
européens c'est à peu près 4 à 5 degrés
de hausse en 10 000 ans
donc là vous avez le résultat d'une
expérience grandeur nature que la
planète a faite pour nous dans le passé
consistant à réchauffer le climat de 4 à
5 degrés en 10.000 ans alors évidemment
ça a été une très bonne affaire pour
nous parce que à cette époque là il y
avait quelques groupes de
chasseurs-cueilleurs occupés à courir
derrière les mammouths et à manger des
Airelles et ça a rendu cultivable toutes
les moyennes latitudes
le nord de la Sibérie aujourd'hui n'est
pas vraiment cultivable on fait pas
vraiment pousser des champs de blé il y
a quelques reines et quelques renards
arctiques et il y a pas beaucoup de
troupeau déloyés il y a pas beaucoup
d'éleveurs donc ça a été une très bonne
affaire à cette époque là
mais aujourd'hui
réchauffez le climat de quelques degrés
en un siècle c'est-à-dire 100 fois plus
rapidement
en appliquant ça à une population
sédentaire de 8 milliards d'individus
vous comprenez bien que malheureusement
la conséquence la plus vraisemblable
c'est que ça va donner beaucoup de
boulot aux gens dans cette salle
c'est malheureusement la conséquence la
plus vraisemblable il est évident que un
monde qui va déstabiliser à une telle
vitesse
les conditions de société sédentaire qui
ne peuvent plus comme à l'époque prendre
leur petit baluchon sur le dos dans
lequel il y aurait les usines les écoles
les ponts les stations d'épuration et
Notre-Dame pour aller installer tous
ailleurs pas faire ça et puis aller où
ou bien vous êtes ailleurs où il y a
déjà des infrastructures pour vivre
comme ici et vous emmerdez quelqu'un et
donc on se bat ou bien ailleurs il y a
pas d'infrastructure parce qu'il y a
personne mais s'il y a pas
d'infrastructure il y a pas
d'infrastructure vous retournez dans les
cavernes avec une peau de bête
donc vous comprenez bien que il y a la
pression que ça va exercer sur des
milliards d'individus sédentaires avec
la vitesse du changement va
malheureusement je vais rentrer un peu
dans le détail mais va malheureusement
être à l'évidence un ferment de conflits
majeurs donc il va falloir beaucoup
beaucoup de courage pour garder la tête
froide dans ce genre de situation
beaucoup de courage
dans les quelques conséquences
et avec un scénario de réchauffement de
2 degrés en haut et un scénario de
réchauffement de 4 degrés en 2100 en bas
le nombre de jours par an c'est le code
couleur que vous avez sur la gauche là
où les conditions extérieures seront
potentiellement mortelles sur terre pour
un individu en bonne santé d'accord
quelqu'un qui passe les tests de
recrutement à l'armée
alors ce que vous voyez c'est que dès
2050 et même pour un scénario de
réchauffement à 2 degrés alors il faut
savoir que dans les scénarios de
réchauffement à deux degrés en fait les
deux degrés on les atteint quasiment dès
2050 mais bon
et bien vous voyez que il y a à peu près
un milliard d'individus donc une bonne
partie de l'Afrique de l'Ouest
toute l'Asie du Sud-Est une partie de
l'Inde une partie de la Chine et une
partie du nord de l'Amérique du Sud
qui se retrouve dans des endroits où
plus d'un jour sur deux il est
impossible de sortir à l'extérieur sans
risquer sa peau alors pourquoi ça
ceux d'entre vous qui sont allés sur des
théâtres d'opération sous les tropiques
enfin exactement l'Équateur le savent
parce que vous vous retrouvez dans des
zones dans lesquelles la température de
l'air dépasse la température de votre
peau donc vous pouvez pas refroidir
votre corps par contact avec l'air et le
degré d'humidité de l'air est tellement
élevé que vous avez beaucoup de mal à
refroidir votre corps en évaporant votre
sueur parce que c'est pas la
transpiration qui vous refroidit c'est
la chaleur latente d'évaporation de la
sueur une fois qu'elle est sur votre
peau
si vous transpirez à grosse goutte sans
pouvoir et vaporer d'eau vous
refroidissez pas
pour se refroidir il faut de la chaleur
de la tente d'évaporation donc ça veut
dire que dans ces régions là plus d'un
jour sur deux vous aurez un taux
d'humidité approchant les 100% avec une
température excédant les 35 degrés en
gros c'est ça que vous aurez question si
vous avez un à avoir 2 milliards
d'individus qui sont dans ces
conditions-là qu'est-ce qu'il qu'est-ce
qui se passe est-ce qu'ils vont rester
tranquille ce qu'ils vont rester calme
ce qui vont rester là où ils sont
probablement pas alors quand vous avez
des masses pareil d'individus qui
bougent ils viennent pas tous chez nous
pas tous dans des plaies à Madame Le Pen
mais par contre ils vont bouger pas loin
de chez eux et ils vont emmerder du
monde pas loin de chez eux et de proche
en proche comme ça ça va augmenter la
conflictualité dans un nombre croissant
de régions dans le monde alors ça peut
donner lieu à des gars civiles ça peut
donner lieu à des gars entre état ça
peut donner lieu à des fortes tensions
je suis pas devin en tout cas ça va pas
dans le bon sens
dans le monde qui va se réchauffer à
cause de l'effet de serre accru il va y
avoir un apparent paradoxe c'est qu'une
bonne partie des sols vont s'assécher
alors c'est un apparent paradoxe parce
que dans un monde plus chaud il y a plus
d'évaporation il y a une capacité
d'emports en vapeur d'eau de
l'atmosphère qui augmente et donc on
s'attendrait à ce qui est plus de
précipitations globalement ça va bien
être le cas manque de chance pour nous
l'essentiel du surplus de précipitation
va tomber sur le Pacifique équatorial où
il est assez difficile de faire pousser
du blé
au dessus des terres émergées vous allez
avoir un certain nombre de processus qui
vont se combiner pour assécher les sols
d'abord les pluies vont tomber sous
forme d'épisodes intenses de façon plus
fréquente si vous avez la même quantité
de pluie qui tombe mais que c'est deux
fois par an comme en Italie la semaine
dernière
c'est pas ça qui vous humidifie les sols
parce qu'à ce moment-là tout part à la
mer après vous avoir inondé la baraque
et ça a pas le temps de s'infiltrer dans
les sols d'accord là il est tombé la
semaine dernière en Italie dans
certaines régions alors que l'Italie
était très sèche il est tombé
l'équivalent de 6 mois de précipitation
d'un coup
ce genre d'épisode va augmenter mais ce
genre d'épisode encore une fois ça fait
des gros inondations mais c'est pas bon
pour la recherche des sols
la deuxième chose qui va augmenter c'est
l'évaporation en provenance des sols
puisque si la température augmente
certes l'évaporation des océans
augmentent mais l'évaporation des sols
augmente aussi et si on combine les deux
il y a beaucoup de régions dans le monde
où les sols vont s'asser et il y a une
particuliers une région qui nous
concerne au premier chef là où la
sèchement va être le plus marqué c'est
le pourtour du bassin méditerranéen
c'est à dire notre région notre région
du reste
[Musique]
j'ai un ami qui est un ancien amiral je
sais pas si on est ancien amiral amiral
en horreur
[Musique]
qui a fondé à Toulon une fondation qui
s'intéresse à la question de stratégie à
l'intérieur de la Méditerranée notamment
sous l'effet des tensions provenant du
réchauffement climatique et j'invite les
gens dans cette salle à aller consulter
les travaux qui fait parce que je pense
que c'est pas totalement sans lien avec
le sujet que j'évoque ce soir
parce qu'elle osseur il s'appelle
à partir de son nom vous retrouverez la
Fondation
méditerranéenne pour les études
stratégiques je crois
ce que vous voyez sur cette carte c'est
donc le pourtour du bassin méditerranéen
va faire ossement s'assécher alors c'est
déjà dans l'actualité il vous aura pas
échappé que l'Espagne en ce moment est
en train de vivre une sécheresse alors
on regarde du passé historique au regard
du futur je ne sais pas peut-être 12
pareil au Maroc le Maroc vit en ce
moment il sécheresse absolument
dantesque déjà l'année dernière ils ont
perdu une partie de leur école de
céréales à peu près la moitié je crois
alors pour le moment ils excellent
mondialisation heureuse pour eux aussi
comme je l'ai dit tout à l'heure ils
exportent plein de phosphates donc ils
peuvent importer la nourriture ça dure
combien de temps cette histoire bon
c'est pareil en Egypte c'est pareil en
Algérie et quand vous regardez les
déclencheurs du printemps arabe il y a
une dizaine d'années vous y trouvez deux
éléments qui sont d'ordre climatiques et
un qui est d'ordre énergétique celui qui
est d'ordre énergétique c'est le pic de
production du pétrole en 2008 qui fiche
le pastis dans les économies
occidentales et qui suppriment les
touristes perte de recettes pour ces
pays-là les deux déterminants
climatiques c'est la sécheresse
endémique que vous avez sur le pourtour
du massant méditerranéen qui interdit à
ces populations d'être autosuffisante en
alimentation et le deuxième déterminant
c'est la canicule qui a eu en Russie en
2010 je sais pas si vous en souvenez qui
a quasiment divisé par deux la
production de céréales cette année-là et
le conflit actuel en Ukraine vous
rappelle que cette région la Russie et
l'Ukraine sont des gros exportateurs de
céréales
résultat le prix de la nourriture monte
au plafond dans ces pays-là qui sont
obligés d'importer alors qu'ils n'ont
plus de recettes à l'exportation parce
qu'il y a pas de touristes et c'est les
émeutes le seul pays où il y a pas
d'émeutes c'est l'Algérie parce qu'il
concerne leurs exportations
d'hydrocarbures
donc vous avez déjà dans le pourtour du
bassin méditerranéen une lecture
possible
du degré de tension qu'il peut y avoir
associé aux paramètres énergie et climat
et aucun des deux ne va malheureusement
aller dans le bon sens à l'avenir
l'Algérie va à passer son pic de
production du pétrole et du gaz
donc l'Algérie va avoir un problème
croissant
de
paiement de dépenses sociales parce que
leur recette à l'exportation vont
baisser
donc là vous avez un petit sujet sur la
production agricole évidemment et vous
avez un petit sujet sur les écosystèmes
le tissu geste sur la production
agricole a conduit le GIEC dans un
rapport sur les terres qui datent il y a
quelques années maintenant quatre ans je
crois a publié ce graphique dans lequel
il disait que à partir de 2 degrés et
demi on va dire de réchauffement
climatique donc je vais y arriver c'est
sur la droite voilà à partir de 2 degrés
et demi de réchauffement global que on
est parti pour atteindre on aurait une
insécurité alimentaire
généralisée sur terre et si vous
regardez l'histoire vous savez que les
gens qui avaient à manger qui n'ont plus
à manger ce qu'ont jamais eu à manger
ils sont jamais très dangereux parce que
ils sont très faibles ils vont pas très
loin ils ont pas fait des civilisations
avec des chars et des avions etc ceux
qui sont dangereux c'est ceux qui ont eu
à manger qu'on fait des chars et des
avions et qu'on puis à manger
voilà cela ils sont très très dangereux
et ce que vous voyez là c'est le risque
que ce genre de détresse là augmente et
bien évidemment c'est pas une bonne
affaire pour nous
il va également y avoir une pression sur
la biodiversité alors ça pourrait être
très franc je ne sais pas dans quelle
mesure ça en Kikine vraiment les
militaires
de savoir qui est moins d'alouette et
moins de mésange enfin ça les enquiquine
peut-être comme individus mais en ce
qu'ils sont militaires je sais pas si
c'est un vrai problème si ça va les
empêcher de faire la guerre ou les
empêcher de la préparer par contre ce
qui est sûr c'est que c'est un peu plus
désagréable pour les civils donc ce que
vous avez ici c'est l'érosion de la
biodiversité essentiellement par
destruction d'habitat ou par destruction
directe d'espèces dans un monde qui se
réchauffe de 2 degrés donc là il s'agit
de 2 degrés c'est à dire l'objectif
politique actuel je vous rappelle donc
dans un monde qui se réchauffe de 2
degrés ce que vous voyez c'est que 80%
des zones considérées aujourd'hui comme
étant de haute importance pour la
biodiversité subissent des pertes
massives de biodiversité
rien qu'à deux degré en fait rien qu'à
1,2 degré ce qui est déjà le cas
aujourd'hui il y a déjà 15% des coraux
qui sont morts par exemple donc voilà
donc ça ça malheureusement ça aussi
c'est en route
la flammabilité des forêts françaises va
augmenter pas que française du reste à
toutes les moyennes latitudes pour ceux
d'entre vous qui suivent l'actualité
vous voyez ce qui se passe au Canada en
ce moment et à nouveau malheureusement
c'est que le début alors ça ça peut
avoir une incidence sur l'armée pourquoi
parce qu'il arrive que l'armée de temps
en temps soit réquisitionné pour des
tâches civiles par exemple protéger les
populations contre les dangers liés aux
catastrophes naturelles donc il est pas
exclu qu'à l'avenir il y a une
réquisition croissante des forces
militaires pour aller s'occuper des gens
qui seront pris au piège des inondations
des incendies etc voilà
accessoirement moi je trouve ça dommage
de voir les forêts brûlées mais si je
m'en tiens strictement aux implications
sur les forces militaires ça peut avoir
un impact à ce niveau là
les phénomènes extrêmes vont
s'intensifier alors pourquoi ils vont
s'intensifier à cause de ce que j'ai dit
tout à l'heure à cause de la différence
de température qui augmente entre la
stratosphère et la basse atmosphère et
donc de la puissance des mouvements
convectifs qui va globalement augmenter
alors les modèles sont capables de
documenter ça sur les ouragans qui sont
des phénomènes de grande échelle et que
on est capable de traiter avec des
modèles climatiques qui ont une maille
qui fait 150 km de côté les modèles
climatiques ne sont pas capables de
documenter ça sur des phénomènes de
petite échelle typiquement les orages
mais enfin si vous regardez l'actualité
météorologique de ces dernières
décennies il n'est pas non plus exclu de
penser par exemple on a eu un épisode de
grêle juste totalement hallucinant
l'année dernière il n'est pas totalement
exclu de penser que en toute bonne
logique ça devrait aussi s'appliquer à
des phénomènes de plus petit échelle
parce qu'à partir du moment où vous avez
un gradient de température qui augmente
ma foi la puissance de la pompe
convictive elle augmente partout il y a
des mouvements convectifs y compris pour
les cumulonimbus probablement
alors pardon là aussi même motif même
punition exactement comme pour les
incendies ou les inondations s'il y a de
plus en plus de population qui sont en
détresse à la suite du passage d'un
ouragan ça peut mobiliser les forces
armées pour ce genre de choses
l'océan va monter alors il va monter le
niveau de l'océan d'abord parce que
l'eau chaude
occupe plus de volume que l'eau froide
vous savez quand on chauffe l'eau elle
se dilate et donc l'expansion thermique
de l'eau va faire monter le niveau des
océans mais sur le long terme ce qui va
dominer c'est la fonte des glaces alors
la fonte des glaces terrestres il y a
des petits glaciers le glacier des
Bossons voilà
glacier du Mont Blanc même si c'est un
glacier que j'aime bien la mer de glace
c'est quand même petit à l'échelle
planétaire les gros glaçons c'est les
calottes c'est à dire le Groenland et
l'Antarctique le Groenland a déjà
commencé à fondre et à partir de
maintenant il y a des processus de
rétroaction positive qui font que il va
continuer à fondre quoi qu'on fasse la
seule question c'est quelle est la
partie qui ne fondra pas parce que elle
sera située dans une cuvette qui etc
enfin bon c'est la seule question donc
là il va y avoir trois à 6 mètres d'eau
en plus dans l'océan mondial en laissant
l'espace de quelques siècles
il y a un risque majeur sur ce qu'on
appelle l'Antarctique de l'Ouest et même
une partie de l'Antarctique de l'Est
dans l'antique de l'Ouest c'est la
partie qui regarde le Chili là c'est
cette partie là avec la Terre de Feu qui
se trouve par là et il y a même une
partie de l'Antarctique de l'Est là
cette partie là qui est à risque
également alors dans les deux cas de
figure le risque provient de la même la
même raison l'Antarctique est pour
laissant et pour une large part pardon
posée sur un socle rocheux qui est
sous-marin ce qui veut dire que le bas
de la calotte est en contact direct avec
l'eau
si l'eau devient plus chaude et si l'eau
se surélève ça grignote par le bas les
langues terminales des glaciers ça les
affaiblit ça fait glisser les glaciers
plus vite vers la mer l'eau s'infiltre
dans les cavités sous-marines sous les
glaciers puisque les glaciers le socle
roncheux est sous marin etc et il y a un
risque de déstabilisation de l'ensemble
de la calotte qui se trouve par ailleurs
être une espèce de château de cartes de
glaciers arc-boutés les uns contre les
autres tenant l'ensemble en équilibre
alors il y a un risque qui est documenté
sur l'Antarctique de l'Ouest où ça
pourrait se désintégrer à partir de 1,5
degrés de réchauffement climatique
dit autrement ça risque vraiment
d'arriver et là on a trois à quatre
mètres d'eau en plus dans l'océan
mondial et on a une partie de
l'Antarctique de l'Est qui est à risque
également à des valeurs un peu
supérieures ce qui veut dire que c'est
comme dans les contrats d'assurance si
vous lisez bien les petites lignes en
2300 alors bon 2300 vous serez morts et
le porte-avion Charles de Gaulle aussi
mais quand même en 2300 il y a un risque
que l'océan mondial monte de plus de 15
mètres par rapport à aujourd'hui ce qui
veut dire qu'il y aura plus un seul port
en activité dans le monde parce que
toutes les villes portuaires sont
aujourd'hui multicellulaires peu de
choses près et vous reconstruisez pas le
port 15 mètres au-dessus quand en 2300
ou en 2200 vous avez plus une goutte de
pétrole à votre disposition en tout cas
vous en construire et plus autant
qu'aujourd'hui donc il y a un petit
sujet
là aussi alors des avant ça je vous ai
pas mis la carte j'aurais dû la mettre
la quantité de submersion marine
c'est-à-dire des phénomènes de type
Xynthia
vont être multipliés par plusieurs
centaines je dis bien plusieurs
centaines d'ici à 2100
plusieurs centaines donc ça ça pose un
problème évidemment au pays dans son
ensemble mais ça pose en particulier un
problème pour les infrastructures
portuaires de l'armée par exemple l'île
Longue face au relèvement du niveau de
la mer qu'est-ce que ça devient voilà
alors ça tombe bien il y a que des
sous-marins peut-être qu'on peut les
laisser sous l'eau en permanence je ne
sais pas
et comme dans un bon James Bond la
mettre un tuyau pour faire mais bon
voilà mais il y a des sujets qui se
posent aussi à l'armée en ce qui
concerne ces infrastructures
l'océan va s'assidifier alors ça va pas
dissoudre les bateaux on va pas passer
en PH acide par contre ça va poser un
problème à la vie marine alors ça ça va
également poser un problème à l'armée un
petit problème je sais pas vous vous
rappellerez probablement qu'on a sorti
la canonnière il y a quelques années
pour aller repousser quelques bateaux de
pêche espagnole dont on considérait
qu'ils avaient rien à faire chez nous si
vous vous rappelez de ça
il se trouve que la vie marine
ayant tendance à s'affaiblir alors pas
que à cause de l'acidification de
l'océan beaucoup à cause de la surpêche
il n'est pas exclu qu'à l'avenir on est
aussi un tout petit sujet de défense des
zones de pêche françaises
et donc on mobilise à nouveau les moyens
militaires pour aller essayer de
préserver les quelques poissons qui nous
restent face à l'appétit des pêcheurs
qui viennent d'ailleurs
bon ça j'ai pas le temps donc je passe
alors dans les militaires
il y a les gendarmes de haute montagne
donc là je vais faire un petit couplet
sur les gendarmes de haute montagne
voilà je sais pas s'il y en a dans la
salle des gens du PGM si on a je les
salue et donc un petit couplet ici vous
avez une face d'une aiguille de Chamonix
qui s'appelle les drues
les Drus et une des comment dire une des
montagnes mythiques de la vallée et en
particulier il y avait un pilier tout
aussi mythique sur les druques qui
s'appelait le pilier Bonatti et bien à
cause du réchauffement climatique le
pilier bonatif est descendu dans la
vallée
alors pourquoi est-ce que le pilier
Bonatti est descendu dans la falaise
parce que ce qui tient la montagne à
haute altitude c'est notamment le
permafrost parce que quand vous êtes à
4000 mètres d'altitude
que vous soyez à côté du Weisshorn ou à
côté du Mont-Blanc j'ai pas raté mon
cool et bien vous avez des températures
qui l'essentiel de l'année sont
négatives et donc vous avez du
permafrost à l'intérieur de la montagne
quand le permafrost commence à dégeler
et bien vous avez une partie du ciment
qui tient les rochers de la montagne qui
peut cesser d'être efficace et à ce
moment il y a un bout de la montagne qui
se casse la gueule vous avez également
un phénomène de gel dégel dans les
fissures qui va jouer alors tant que
c'est en dessous de zéro en permanence
vous n'avez pas de dégel donc vous avez
pas de problème mais quand vous avez gel
des ailes comme vous savez la glace
occupe plus de volume que l'eau et donc
vous avez un phénomène de bélier
cryogénique quelque part qui peut finir
éventuellement par faire descendre le
pilier des drogues
voilà donc ça c'était un petit clin
d'oeil enfin je sais pas si c'est un
clin d'oeil pour les militaires qui vont
sauver des victimes en haute montagne
qui seront également un peu plus
mobilisés peut-être
l'été dernier j'ai pas si vous avez eu
cette information mais les guides
refusaient de monter sur le Cervin qui a
un tas de cailloux pourri maintenu en
place par le gel justement
la première cordée qui a fait le Cervin
il y a une personne sur deux qui est
parvenue les guides ont refusé de monter
sur le serveur l'été dernier à cause de
l'excès de la température tellement
importante qu'ils avaient peur de se
prendre un bout de la montagne sur la
figure
bon alors ça ne concerne que les gens
riches quand les moyens de faire
l'alpinisme mais ça concerne un petit
peu aussi le encore une fois les
militaires qui auront peut-être à faire
face aux conséquences d'éboulement de
terrain de plus en fin ou d'éboulement
de montagne plus exactement de plus en
plus fréquents à l'avenir
voilà alors je vais pas encore faire la
longue liste il y a un vrai risque de
ralentissement de la dérive
nord-atlantique qui est la prolongation
du Goldstream qui amène de la chaleur en
Europe en allant mourir au sud du
Groenland c'est pareil si ce truc là
commence à se modifier à large échelle
la modification régionale des climats
mettre un nécessairement le pastis en
Europe et c'est pas exclu que ça donne
aussi du travail aux gens dans cette
salle
les maladies endémiques vont voir leur
zone se déplacer alors ça ça concerne la
santé des militaires quand ils sont sur
leur théâtre d'opération parce que comme
tout le monde ils peuvent tomber malade
bon il y a des phénomènes
d'amplification possible etc et puis
garder le meilleur pour la fin
nous ne sommes pas au restaurant où vous
avez une carte avec tous les plats qui
sont très exactement décrits à l'avance
et vous avez que ces plats là et rien
que c'est là d'accord en surface si vous
faites vraiment les yeux doux au serveur
ou à la serveuse pour avoir une petite
exception avec un gros supplément mais
globalement c'est surtout dans les
restaurants parisiens donc là mais en
gros
vous savez vous avez une liste finie là
malheureusement on n'a pas une liste
finie d'enverdements qui peuvent nous
tomber sur la figure parce que nous
sommes en train de faire une expérience
pour la première fois et chaque insecte
quand on fait une expérience pour la
première fois la seule chose de certaine
c'est qu'on sait pas tout à l'avance
les militaires sont bien placés pour le
savoir puisque normalement vous avez des
organisations qui vous permettent de
faire face à un nombre raisonnable de
surprises je dis bien raisonnable
donc là on va avoir un vrai sujet aussi
de de préparation face à l'imprévu alors
ça concerne évidemment les activités
civiles mais pas que ça va aussi
concerner les activités militaires
et je vais finir par ça
le micro qui se déplace donc j'ai
compris le signe mais c'est bien
j'arrive à la fin je vais finir par ça
qui est l'ampleur du défi si on ne veut
pas se prendre des conséquences massives
du réchauffement climatique sur la
figure qui va nous ramener au point de
départ c'est à dire la sobriété et ça
répartition entre activités civile et
activités militaire avant même de parler
de la répartition au sein même des
activités civiles
comme le CO2 est une espèce chimique
extrêmement stable dans l'atmosphère la
seule chose qui compte pour avoir
l'élévation de température de
l'atmosphère à un instant donné c'est
combien de CO2 on a mis dans
l'atmosphère jusqu'à maintenant
afin 2022
depuis le début de leur industriel et
essentiellement depuis le début de la
seconde depuis là pas dans la fin de la
Seconde Guerre mondiale l'humanité a mis
dans l'atmosphère à peu près 2400
milliards de tonnes de CO2 conduisant au
réchauffement de 1,2 degré dont je vous
ai parlé tout à l'heure et le cadre
réchauffement de 1,2 degré a déjà tué
15% des coraux et tuera 20 à 30% de la
forêt française à climat constant 20%
allez parce que les arbres sont déjà
hors de leur zone de confort sur le sur
le long terme
si on veut limiter le réchauffement à
1,5 degrés ce qui est l'objectif
politique actuel il faut limiter les
émissions cumulées de l'humanité à 3000
milliards de tonnes dont 2400 déjà été
émise
d'accord Xavier 3000 euros de budget
vous en avez déjà dépensé 2400 vous
aurez 600 d'accord avec moi pourtant
dépenser plus que 600
ce qui veut dire que tenir les 1,5
degrés c'est émettre collectivement
d'ici à la fin du siècle le quart de ce
que nous avons aimé sur les 100 voir les
80 ans qui viennent de s'écouler le car
avec une population qui était en moyenne
2,5 fois moins nombreuses sur la période
ça revient à dire que le budget carbone
d'un bébé qui naît aujourd'hui et le
dixième sur sa vie du budget carbone de
ses grands-parents qui meurent
aujourd'hui
et comme le carbone c'est l'énergie et
l'énergie c'est les biens de
consommation industrielles que nous
avons à notre disposition ça revient
quelque paradis que le scénario 1,5
degrés c'est accepter de façon délibérée
que le pouvoir d'achat sur sa vie
entière d'un bébé qui naît aujourd'hui
soit le dixième du pouvoir d'achat de
ses grands-parents qui m'a aujourd'hui
voilà c'est ça que ça revient à dire en
gros
tous les gens qui pensent que on va pas
y arriver
pense nécessairement je vous dis pas ce
que je pense pas pense nécessairement
que toutes les conséquences que je viens
de décrire vont s'appliquer de manière
plus ample avec évidemment les risques
de conflits associés
si on veut les deux degrés on est un peu
plus lâche on a droit à 3600 dont 2400
déjà émises mon bébé il a droit au 5e du
pouvoir d'achat de ses grands-parents
sur sa vie durant mais en gros du
pouvoir d'achat matériel j'entends je
parle pas du poids d'achat culturel
spirituel etc matériel les mètres carrés
les tonnes les kilos les machins les
trucs voilà les mètres carrés de
moquette les kilos de jouer à Noël enfin
voilà des trucs comme ça
les kilos de nourriture tout ça
vous comprenez bien que on est face à
quelque chose qui est extrêmement dur et
donc
c'est pas fini le titre soit tu auras la
guerre soit tu auras l'économie de
guerre en gros c'est la conclusion de
cette affaire
l'économie de guerre c'est la diminution
des émissions de 5% par an qu'il
faudrait avoir à partir de maintenant
tous les ans pour être capable de tenir
les deux degrés
ce qui je peux vous le dire de plusieurs
manières revient à avoir chaque année un
covid supplémentaire puisque l'un des du
covid on a baissé les émissions
planétaires de 5%, et bien pose covid on
remet pas l'économie dans lequel dans
l'état dans lequel elle était avant le
covid on la garde comme elle est puis on
rajoute un covid supplémentaire
d'accord donc on demande au pangolin ou
au laboratoire de one je ne sais pas
exactement
de nous mettre une deuxième saloperie en
circulation puis l'année d'après une
troisième etc c'est ça que ça veut dire
sinon je vais prendre un parallèle un
point historique militaire là pour le
coup 5% de baisse des émissions c'est
également ce que nous avons eu sur Terre
en 1945 c'est-à-dire l'année de
l'éradication de l'appareil industriel
de l'Allemagne et du Japon
voilà ça ça fait 5% de baisse aussi
et il faudrait avoir 5% de baisse tous
les ans à partir de maintenant pour
tenir les deux degrés il y a un papier
qui est sorti il y a pas longtemps dans
un journal qui s'appelle ecological
economics
qui a été vulgarisé sur un site de
vulgarisation de la recherche s'appelle
The condressation je sais pas si ça vous
connaissez et dont le titre est
faudra-t-il se mettre en économie de
guerre pour respecter les accords de
Paris et si vous faites une réponse
brutale que les auteurs ne font pas mais
que moi je fais quand vous lisez
l'article la réponse est oui
c'est à dire qu'il faut doubler la
formation brute de capital fixe passer
devant à 40% mettre tout le monde au
travail baisser la consommation et
voilà en gros c'est exactement ça donc
ça fait une économie de guerre
voilà donc c'est ça la fin de cette
exposé extrêmement réjouissant
ce jeudi a un peu plus de 18h30 et
maintenant je m'arrête et s'il y a des
questions c'est bien volontiers
[Applaudissements]
pardon je vous précise que j'ai une
règle paritaire pour les questions
donc c'est successivement un homme une
femme un homme une femme voilà je ne
dérange pas
bonjour monsieur merci pour
votre intervention alors je consultant
en intelligence économique pour gazer
l'énergie ma question ce serait sur les
sanctions
notamment énergétiques qu'on a mis
vis-à-vis de la Russie
quelles conséquences pour l'Europe là
pour les années à venir comment vous
analysez
la conséquence pour l'Europe c'est que
on a fait un pari qui était que bien
évidemment il n'y a pas eu de connexion
entre les sanctions envers la Russie et
la décarbonation par ailleurs planifiée
fit for fifty-five etc de l'Europe on
n'a pas du tout fait la connexion entre
les deux
et le Paris qui a été fait au moment où
on a pris ses sanctions c'est qu'on
pourrait très facilement se retourner en
termes de pétrole et de gaz vers
d'autres fournisseurs
on est en train de se rendre compte que
c'est pas si simple que ça pour plein de
pour plein de raisons ce qui veut dire
que on a fait le pari en fait avec ses
sanctions de d'aller un peu plus vite
vers la décarbonation subie de nos
activités et ça ça va se faire
essentiellement par suppression d'usage
donc on va avoir des problèmes on a déjà
du reste on a eu des problèmes de prix
qui ont conduit les gens à baissé leur
consommation alors pourquoi est-ce que
c'est pas si facile que ça de se
retourner parce que je vous ai dit tout
à l'heure je vous ai montré sur la
production de pétrole en fait la
production de pétrole des 16 premiers
fournisseurs de l'Europe ne retrouvera
pas probablement poszkovite son niveau
d'avant covid mais même pour l'ensemble
des pays dans le monde c'est
probablement le cas aussi à date le
maximum historique de la production de
pétrole dans le monde c'était novembre
ce qui veut dire que si on se prive du
pétrole russe qui représentait un tiers
des importations européennes on n'a pas
d'autres endroits où le trouver sauf à
jouer à un jeu de chaise musicale qui
revient à ne pas sanctionner Poutine
c'est-à-dire les Russes se mettent à
vendre leur pétrole à d'autres personnes
qui du coup ne l'achètent plus aux
producteurs auquel il l'a acheté avant
qui du coup peuvent nous le vendre
mais ça empêche pas les Russes
d'exporter leur pétrole parce que de
toute façon on est au taquet
question-production mondiale et ce qui
se passe en pratique et du reste que la
presse commence à évoquer c'est que les
Russes vendent leur pétrole aux Indiens
qu'il raffine et qui nous le vendent
en ce qui concerne le gaz
alors là c'est un peu plus sportif
on a compensé une partie de
l'utilisation du gaz qu'on utilisait en
utilisant plus de charbon dans la
production électrique on en a compensé
une partie grâce au réchauffement
climatique qui a fait un hiver très doux
l'hiver dernier donc la consommation de
gaz pour le chauffage qui est un gros
usage a été plus basse et puis par
ailleurs le niveau de prix a fait que la
consommation a été encore plus basse
donc les gens ont sorti des quoi les
couettes et des pulls et ils ont
consommé moins de gaz et il y en a une
partie qu'on a réussi à compenser avec
du GNL mais une partie seulement dont en
ce moment les infrastructures sont en
construction partout mais ça ne compense
pas un pour un le l'approvisionnement
qui qui venait de Russie
alors qui est la femme qui se dévoue
j'ai une main qui élevée là non Ah bah
non il y avait une autre
merci beaucoup pour pour la conférence
ce soir je voulais vous demander parce
qu'aujourd'hui on peut voir que la
guerre elle se fait de plus en plus dans
le cyberespace et on sait on constate
que l'informatique c'est un milieu qui
est extrêmement énergivore et
extrêmement demandeur de ressources donc
comment est-ce que vous vous estimez
cette gestion du manque d'énergie et de
ressources face à une menace hiver qui
est de plus en plus grandissante en
particulier dans le milieu militaire
alors pour le coup le lien il est
indirect c'est à dire que le lien il est
lié au fait que pour pouvoir mener des
attaques cybers il faut un peu de
matériel informatique soi-même mais vous
arrivez à avoir un peu de matériel
informatique vous-même à des coûts qui
ne sont pas monstrueux à partir du
moment où la production globale de
matériel informatique c'est juste un
problème d'effet d'échelle est
importante à l'échelle de la planète dit
autrement si on ne produisait des
ordinateurs que pour mener des attaques
cybers contre les ordinateurs militaires
de l'ennemi
le coût des ordinateurs sera
effectivement extrêmement élevé parce
que ça nécessiterait d'avoir toute une
filière rien que pour ça mais en fait
comme on produit essentiellement des
ordinateurs pour faire des conférences
dans cette salle enfin exactement on
produit essentiellement des ordinateurs
pour des particuliers et des usages
courants d'entreprises ça permet aussi
d'avoir des ordinateurs pour pas cher
pour des gens qui sont animés
d'attention moins sympathique
vis-à-vis de des gens qui le vivent donc
effectivement l'abondance énergétique a
aussi eu pour effet j'ai passé
exactement ça à votre question mais une
des conséquences de l'abondance
énergétique c'est que ça a eu pour effet
de multiplier la possibilité
d'avoir des gens qui s'équipent en
moyenne numérique en moyenne digitaux
pour mener des attaques auprès d'autres
personnes ça a une autre conséquence
alors par contre la digitalisation crée
une vulnérabilité en tant que tel parce
que vous avez aujourd'hui un certain
nombre de processus vitaux à court terme
qui dépend du numérique le premier
d'entre eux c'est le fonctionnement du
système monétaire aujourd'hui système
monétaire mondial c'est des ordinateurs
ce n'est que ça donc si on a plus
d'ordinateur on a plus de système
monétaire mondial peu compliqué vous
avez également tous les systèmes de
communication et l'armée ne dépend pas
que de système de communication durci il
y a aussi des systèmes de communication
ordinaire je suis sûr qu'une partie des
communications passe par des portables
ordinaires donc vous avez même si son
cryptés
vous avez une vulnérabilité également
liée au fait que vous devez maintenir
ces systèmes-là en opération si vous
voulez que le pays c'est derrière la
fois soit l'armée soit sa base arrière
continue de continuer de fonctionner
est-ce que l'énergie utilisée par les
cyber-attaquants est un problème non
c'est un peu d'électricité c'est pas
grand chose en fait l'énergie dont il
dépend des essentiellement l'énergie qui
alimente le réseau mondial qui permet à
leurs instructions d'aller de
l'ordinateur où ils essayent de passer
les attaques vers l'ordinateur attaqué
d'accord elle est là l'énergie dont il
dépendent vraiment mais celle-là elle
est mutualisée elle est pas elle est pas
propre j'ai envie de dire à l'attaquant
elle est propre au système dans son
ensemble
ça répond à la question ou si
dans un sens comme dans l'autre
donc maintenant j'ai besoin d'un homme
mais vous êtes sur la file d'attente pas
de problème
allô oui bonsoir monsieur jean-clauvici
je cite une phrase que vous avez que
vous avez donné dans une autre
conférence vous avez dit avec moins de
pétrole et une économie qui n'est pas
capable de se décarboner à la bonne
vitesse on a globalement moins
d'économies oui donc qui dit moi
d'économie si on vous suit dit moins de
PNB moins de PMB moins de consommation
d'énergie est-ce que ça nous donne pas
une petite dimension positive quand même
histoire qu'on finisse bien la soirée en
se disant qu'au fond le système va
s'auto réguler comme les asservissements
machines des tanks alors c'est sûr que
le système va s'auto réguler la seule
question c'est est-ce qu'on va trouver
ça sympathique ou pas
c'est la seule question mais sinon bien
sûr que oui le système va s'auto réguler
moi je suis plutôt partisan qui
s'autorégule avec notre consentement et
avec notre volonté plutôt que sans notre
consentement et sans notre volonté mais
sinon il y a strictement aucun on va
avoir une forme de loi de Lavoisier qui
va s'appliquer à nous une fois qu'on est
hors d'équilibre on va revenir à
l'équilibre donc voilà mais il vaudrait
mieux que ce soit pas trop douloureux
après j'ai dit tout à l'heure que la
sobriété en fait elle affaiblissait de
fait physiquement la base arrière
physiquement alors il y a des
affaiblissements qui sont pas graves
c'est pas très grave si on affaiblit la
base arrière et que les gens mettent un
quart d'heure de plus pour aller au
boulot en prenant un vélo plutôt qu'une
voiture c'est pas très grave je pense
pas que fondamentalement ça soit un
affaiblissant un affaiblissement gérable
on va dire par contre il y a des
affaiblissements de la base arrière qui
peuvent être plus ennuyeux parce que
vous vous rendez compte que l'appareil
militaire dépend exactement comme j'ai
dit tout à l'heure que les hackers
c'était un petit bout du digital mondial
et sans digital mondial il y aurait pas
les hacker il y a des il y a des
industries c'est l'armée peut bénéficier
de cette industrie parce qu'elle existe
aussi pour les civils et qu'elle est
globalement grosse
voilà ça alors à ce stade le la question
de savoir où est-ce qu'on peut
facilement dissocier les deux et où
est-ce qu'on peut plus difficilement
dissocier les deux à mon avis c'est un
travail à mener c'est-à-dire je ne pense
pas qu'aujourd'hui le travail a été fait
aussi project on l'a pas fait ça c'est
sûr je pense que le travail a pas été
fait mais c'est un travail qui serait
intéressant à faire c'est-à-dire où
est-ce que où est-ce que on se met en
risque quelque part
en termes de capacité à réagir et où
est-ce qu'on ne se met pas en risque
ma question porte sur ce pan de la
recherche scientifique actuellement qui
travaille sur les nouvelles sources
d'énergie par exemple
issues du travail sur les algues est-ce
qu'à votre sens c'est une utopie ou
est-ce que ça permettrait d'aider dans
ce travail de répartition des énergies
entre le monde civil le monde militaire
alors là les nouvelles sources d'énergie
[Musique]
quand on regarde leur potentiel il faut
regarder plusieurs choses il faut
regarder la quantité globale disponible
ce qui souvent pour les énergies
renouvelables n'est pas d'un sujet parce
qu'il y en a beaucoup il faut regarder
leur état de concentration dans
l'environnement
ça ça peut commencer à devenir un sujet
et enfin il faut regarder le rendement
de transformation entre l'énergie qu'on
prélève dans l'environnement et
l'énergie utile qu'on va pouvoir mettre
dans une machine donc en l'occurrence
des carburants de l'électricité c'est ça
qu'on va mettre dans une machine
en ce qui concerne les algues je n'ai
regardé aucun des trois points donc je
n'ai pas regardé le potentiel primaire
c'est à la quantité d'algues produite
sur les côtes et qu'on pourrait
facilement récolter donc la biomasse
brute on va dire et j'ai pas regardé les
rendements de conversion il y a
plusieurs types de conversion on peut
métaliser utiliser le métal
éventuellement derrière pour faire des
carburants liquides on peut faire du
fisher-up à partir du méthane et faire
des carburants liquides va le rendement
je le connais c'est 50%
on peut les faire sécher les brûler les
forces etc donc il y a plusieurs
manières de les utiliser très
honnêtement j'ai pas regardé la seule
chose que je peux vous dire c'est que ça
fait 20 ans que j'entends parler des
algues alors pas en l'occurrence en les
ramassant sur les plages mais plutôt en
les faisant pousser dans des grandes
balles dans des grands bassins avec des
algues très riches en huile
ça fait 20 ans que j'en entends parler
et ça fait 20 ans que je ne vois pas de
démonstrateur à grande échelle et ça
fait 20 ans que je me dis qu'il faudrait
que j'aille regarder d'un peu plus près
pour comprendre pourquoi et ça fait 20
ans que je le fais pas voilà mais mais
j'ai malheureusement malheureusement pas
la réponse à votre question par contre
j'ai le j'ai le discours de la méthode
encore une fois pour toutes les énergies
qu'on pourrait utiliser faut voir la
quantité totale la diffusion dans
l'environnement et là où le bât blesse
par exemple avec le solaire et l'éolien
c'est sur ce point là c'est à dire que
ces énergies sont diffuses et donc elles
sont coûteuses à extraire de
l'environnement il faut beaucoup de
collecteurs placés en beaucoup
d'endroits pour extraire des grandes
quantités de l'environnement parce que
c'est des énergies diffusent le pétrole
c'est très concentré le nucléaire c'est
très concentré même l'hydroélectricité
c'est assez concentré
et il faut regarder le rendement c'est
ça le c'est ça le c'est ça les trois
points à regarder
après il y a une question là
il faut rendre l'amphi pardon
sinon les pompiers nous mettent dehors
ah bon
c'est génial qui
moi je ne sais pas quel est votre
rapport de force avec les forces de
sécurité qui pilote l'amphi
bien j'ai donc le privilège dernière je
pense une question aviation je suis
aviateur vous nous expliquez que
considérant l'aviation dans son ensemble
les carburants de synthèse n'étaient pas
une piste qui passerait à l'échelle
parce que les rendements sont trop
faibles et donc les coûts de production
trop importante maintenant s'agissant du
particularisme de l'aviation de combat
des avions de chasse qui demain comme
aujourd'hui qui soit piloté à distance
ou de l'intérieur des cockpites
continueront de peser 15 à 20 tonnes de
devoir monter à 50000 pieds et d'être
supersonique considérant ce micro
domaine et ce qui n'est pas envisageable
et considérant par ailleurs que les
fonctions remplissent cette aviation de
combat n'ont pas d'alternative connue en
l'état de l'art n'est-il pas urgent
intéressant faisable de s'intéresser au
développement d'une filière étatique de
carburant de synthèse à destination des
armées
pour ma paroisse à destination de
l'action de combat qui permettrait de
maintenir et de remplir cette fonction
qui n'a pas d'alternative alors la
question que vous posez en fait je l'ai
indirectement abordé dans la question
que je vous ai posé tout à l'heure qui
est de savoir comment est-ce que la
collectivité arbitrerait les moyens
résiduels quand il n'y en aurait plus
pour tout le monde donc à partir du
moment où il y a plus assez de
carburants pour les avions de combat et
les gilets jaunes et les camionneurs et
Monsieur ou Madame Michu qui chauffe-eau
fioul dans la Creuse bien la question
c'est à qui va le pétrole restant et
donc la question que vous posez relève
pour moi du choix démocratique
idéalement éclairé quand il est pas
éclairé c'est quand même moins
sympathique dans lequel on regarde les
faits en face dont j'ai essayé de vous
exposer une partie et où on se dit
collectivement notre préférence elle va
plutôt dans le fait que on est encore
quelques avions qui tournent dans le
ciel il y a quelques avions de combat et
une fois on partagera la voiture avec le
voisin c'est pas si grave voilà c'est
c'est ça ça fait partie des questions
qui se posent et en venant chez vous ce
soir
[Musique]
donc j'ai je suis très heureux d'avoir
été invité parce que ces questions là
sont globalement absentes du débat
environnemental et écologique
c'est-à-dire le il y a
le débat écologique dans la presse dans
etc c'est de façon
se tuer entre se tuer entre humains
c'est pas bon donc on parle pas des
sujets de l'armée voilà je suis tout à
fait d'accord avec le premier prémisse
sauf que le monde étant ce qu'il est de
temps en temps et puis vous connaissez
comme moi le dieu dicton romain hein si
tu veux la paix etc donc je pense que la
question se pose quand même mais j'ai
pas la réponse aujourd'hui donc dire
qu'il y a une filière étatique c'est
dire que la collectivité a fait le choix
d'arbitrer en votre faveur
c'est exactement ça voilà ce qui est un
sujet dont il faut discuter
ça me paraît évident
alors Monsieur Monsieur Jean d'argent
covici vous l'avez dit vous l'avez fait
vous avez complètement et parfaitement
adapté votre discours à l'auditoire en
liant les armées et les problématiques
liées au climat à l'énergie donc merci
beaucoup
vous savez pour les militaires des
images de chevaux de chars de bateau ça
nous parle forcément
et mais pour être totalement honnête il
manquait peut-être une voiture bleue
avec un gyrophare voilà pour être
totalement objectif dans votre
dans vos exemples sur la puissance
et en parlant de gendarmerie d'ailleurs
vous avez un officier du qui commandait
le pg-hm de Chamonix qui est juste là et
qui vous remercie pour le pour le clin
d'œil
[Musique]
cet événement je vous donne à tous
rendez-vous pour la prochaine conférence
du de l'école de guerre qui aura lieu
mercredi prochain
qui accueillera donc Édouard Philippe
sur commander et gouverner
il me reste monsieur Jean-Claude
Jean-Marc Jancovici pardon
puisque l'école de guerre c'est aussi
une maison d'édition
j'ai le plaisir de vous offrir deux
ouvrages qui ont été écrits par de nos
grands anciens anciens élèves de l'école
de guerre qui vous font un souvenir de
votre passage et encore une fois merci
beaucoup
merci beaucoup